this is Jocko podcast number 182 with
echo Charles and me jogo willing good
evening a couple good evening the
insertion was flawless we were in the
wood line and on our way for a general
area reconnaissance this time we played
it by the book moving ten minutes than
waiting ten minutes as we moved I swore
that I'd never run an eight-man team
again it's too cumbersome in this target
the vegetation still made me a tad on
edge as it had a second canopy in some
areas but still gave us long lines of
sight something we weren't used to as
darkness approached we looked for a good
spot to our o n with the flat terrain
finding a good ro n became really dicey
ordinarily we'd look for high ground
dense vegetation or an area far from any
trail finally we found one and South set
up a perimeter set up the watch rotation
and oversaw the placement of extra
claymore mines in one area where the
vegetation was thin Bubba placed a
couple of tow poppers in the ground I
couldn't sleep the flat terrain played
on my mind before first light the entire
team was awake alert retrieving the
claymore mines and preparing for our
move out of the RO end after a night on
the jungle floor I wanted an R&R
anywhere with firm beds clean sheets and
cold drinks because I insisted on
carrying the PRC 25 there was little
room in my backpack except for
essentials at night when I slept on the
ground I did so without an air mattress
or hammock the sole item of comfort was
an army-issue pullover sweater that
buttoned up to the neck whenever I put
it on at night I was always worried
about Charlie hitting us when I was
pulling the sweater over my head it was
one of the few creature comforts I
allowed myself or had room for in my
rucksack
shortly after first light the Green
Hornet's CNC aircraft flew into the edge
of our AO
for a routine Comeau check I gave him a
quick team okay and prepared to move the
team out of the RO n however the C and C
crew told me to wrap up the mission
there was another problem that he
couldn't discuss on an open frequency we
knew the NVA monitored SOG FM radio
transmissions and had radio
direction-finding equipment the CNC
pilot told us to find an LZ and let and
to let him know when we'd be ready for
extraction a few minutes later the Green
Hornet's roared into the new LZ picked
us up and returned us to base the reason
we were yanked from the field this time
stemmed from a tragedy in the Prairie
fryer area of operations on 30 November
and age 34 king b was shot out of the
sky during an eldest son operation seven
green berets from fo b 1 and fo b 4 were
killed when an anti-aircraft round
struck the sikorsky chopper and ignited
the ammunition on the aircraft killing
everyone on board one of the men killed
and that ill-fated king B was Staff
Sergeant Arthur e Bader I liked Bader on
my last night at fo b1 before shipping
out to fo b6 I played in a poker game
where he won a lot of money the longer
we played the more money Bader won the
more money Boehner won the more morose
he became at one point I asked him what
was wrong he was winning and he was
ahead several hundred dollars but kept
complaining that he'd never spend the
money his response was that he had a
premonition that he was going to die and
that men about to die often win a lot of
money money that they would never spend
we all tried to Josh him out of his dark
mood but failed Bader was a unique
Special Forces Green Beret he had earned
and lost three separate fortunes in
between three terms in the service he
was in his 30s but still enjoyed SF
spoke fluent German and a few other
languages and merely wanted to
any mission assigned to him on the
flight on the long flight back to Phu
Bai I kept hearing him talk to us at the
poker table that last night now he was
gone
now he was gone
and that is the reality of war captured
in the best-selling book across the
fence and back with us again to talk
about war as the author of that book and
of another book called on the ground and
of a series of books called the SOG
chronicles a man who has seen more than
most and who has had more close calls
than any man should have John the
striker Meyer and if you haven't
listened to podcast 180 and 180 one yet
go back and listen to them first to hear
the background of this hero this warrior
Special Forces soldier and leader of RT
Idaho a recon team for Mac V SOG working
missions across the border from Vietnam
into Laos and Cambodia John good evening
sir
good evening thanks for coming back
again plan to be back every time you
walk out the studio about ten minutes
later I said you attack say hey can you
come back again next week we'd have so
much fun I can't say no that's happened
that's that happened that's both that's
how you ended up here again every time
you walk out of here I go
I want to hear to hear you talk more
hear more about what you've done and ya
know it's been awesome and the response
from people have been hitting me up
they've been just just enthralled with
what you've been talking about and here
in here and you tell these stories has
been and has been interesting and you
haven't seen this have you heard of a
movie character named Jason Bourne this
guy yeah okay yeah so I posted a picture
of you when you were 21 or 20 or 22
he's my illegitimate son
yeah they've got some definite comments
about that interesting so yeah we got
the the real guy back again so I know we
have that first excerpt that I just read
was from across the fence and I wanted
to go back to your other book for a
little bit the book on the ground and
then I just want to I got a bunch of
things I want to just ask you about and
talk to you about but I wanted to cover
one more section of this book on the
ground I was reading through it again
yesterday and it's just again one of
these situations where I don't know how
you're here right now to be honest with
you only buddy grace of God indeed the
Recon guides to smiled on our team and
you know I you guys had more than 100
percent casualty rate correct you had
guys that you had some guys that had
seven eight nine purple hearts Bob
Howard was put in for 11 he only
received 8 in my case I've been put in
for 2 more but it's just shrapnel mmm
you know you look at guys who get two
legs blown off arms Blancas like almost
embarrassed to take it and and anybody
got a Purple Heart in our day you got
really rag for it yeah because they you
dumbass he just couldn't get out of the
way fast enough she got a Purple Heart
yeah I think we had is one of my old
Vietnam seal buddies I think he called
it the the Vietcong Achievement Medal
was the Purple Heart that's a good I
like that
so you're put in for two more how many
did you get already almost had one okay
and again spider parks and Pat Watkins
my you know my gurus my recon gurus we
had one that have been put in for just
minor strappin all the paperwork
disappeared another one had more
shrapnel and this time with a little bit
a lot more serious bleeding and
scratching and stuff a little blood
nothing serious compared to what guys
for sure they're really good hammered
they said no put in for it someday you
may have to go to the VA right afters VA
even though the benefits it's there you
give home loans oh okay
that might be a future if we get through
this there might be a future some that
had dope Dan 20 mom after three purple
hearts was that a rule no that's this
not a nun sock what about a normal
soldier I wouldn't know I never spent
any time in a regular unit yeah no I
mean Bob Howard he took his 8 and he
should have had 11 all the cluster they
guess they ran out of clusters for those
yeah and you talk about in saw
Chronicles vol 1 what was it 16 guys
went out 16 Special Forces soldiers went
out and they got 33 purple hearts in
four days oh yeah and probably could
have gotten more sure ridiculous
absolutely this is crazy yeah yeah all
right we're going back to on the ground
here we go the Huey's lifted off made
gentle lazy turn and pointed their noses
Northwest once everyone was settled I
allowed my mind to wander as I looked
out and marveled how beautiful landscape
was from several thousand feet up in the
air up where it was open and cool rather
than closed in muggy there was also a
sense of inner peace and pride this is
what I had volunteered and trained so
hard for this chance to run top-secret
missions behind enemy lines dangerous
missions that made a difference like
most special forces types I couldn't
stomach the monotonous routines of camp
life the ash and trash detail stuff the
petty rules regulations formations and
egos more amazing yet here I was at the
ripe old age of 22 sporting the exalted
rank of efore and the one zero of a SOG
recon team 22 years old young and dumb
yeah 22 years old and you'd been bus if
you hadn't been but you got busted down
once or twice only once okay so you
would have been an e5 you think at this
point I would have been up most of
powerful yes cease any fire
that must have been called crazy because
usually you got promoted based one if
you're running missions
whenever the appropriate time frame was
to be in one grape if we be considered
for the next SOG was really good about
getting the promotions at least our
people so as soon as you accomplish your
time in rank don't you get out with me
do Stevie for really quick so when you
this this idea of being an SF and just
being on camp and on base and having the
the normal kind of routines you just
couldn't stand that no you just would
rather be out in the field oh yeah just
tries you nuts yeah all right here we go
back to the book I had been with Artie
Idaho for seven months now
by dint of hard work lots of mission
experience and simply having survived
I was now a team leader at a moment's
notice I could have millions and
millions of dollars worth of air support
assets some of them manned by majors and
lieutenant Colonel's all doing my
bidding
all giving their courageous best to save
my bacon I had come a long way since
flunking out of college and doing a
stint as a garbage collector in Yosemite
National Park Park my egotistical
reveries were cut short when the door
gunner on my side of the Huey decided to
cut loose with a long burst of m60
machine gun fire right next to my ear
fortunately he was simply test firing it
your you know we would get I guess it's
kind of similar is we be driving to a
target right being in a Humvee yeah you
know sometimes the targets are an hour
sometimes two hours you know we did some
long long transits but you would get
time to sit there and think about stuff
because well you're geared you're
sitting there being transported there's
not too much you can do you know you're
scanned and you're looking for but
you're in a helicopter there's nothing
to do but think really it was always
amazing because it's just so beautiful
I mean Southeast Asia from the air even
when you went over a combat zone you see
the bomb craters me but the jungle
it was just this beautiful country and
then look you get under it and get into
the underbelly the jungle dislike those
you know it's another whole world
the Starling contrast you know there and
like you if you're in the desert it has
its own beauty yeah and it can be
spellbinding if you just watch it oh wow
look at this that without realized that
somewhere there's a little hole some guy
could pop out up a hitch with an RPG or
detonate in your case does remote
controls yeah when you roll over did you
it sounds like you recognize this when
you were doing these operations you kind
of knew that this was I don't know I I
guess I'm gonna use this word you were
lucky to be there oh clearly because I
want a hundred percent when I was in
Iraq and I only did two deployments to
Iraq i 100% knew every day that I was
there I knew that this was like my time
this is what I'd been this is what I
would lived for and I knew that it
wasn't like I look back and say I went
really wish I would have appreciated
those days know when I was in them I
completely knew it and appreciated being
there like every single day yeah and
like I it was a nice feeling personally
to think that here we are with the best
of the best and we're running the
missions and that's we live for it okay
now we're here let's go do this and just
hope get the mission done and just was
the damn trackers who leave you alone so
you get the mission done good doodle
wiretapper snatch up eow something like
that oh yeah it felt good but you know
it's like quiet professionals you just
don't talk about that much yeah going
back to the book as we approach the LZ
the team crowded the two doors of the
helicopter I was on the right half
standing on the skid Sawa's kneeling
behind me his hand on my shoulder ready
to follow me out the door next to him
was kept my 1 1 John Bubba sure along
with fuck our point man and Tuan our
Grenadier got ready to exit
out the left side door we all kept her
eyes riveted on the looming jungle
scanning for any signs of movement in
the treeline surrounding our LZ the top
of the Triple Canopy growth of trees
vines and other vegetation was at least
a hundred feet off the jungle floor and
the opening into which we were
descending reminded me of the mouth of a
long dark tunnel at the bottom of which
resided things Alice never dreamed of
when she tumbled into that rabbit hole
of hers as we were swallowed up and the
darkness increased a cold chill ran down
my spine when you're going into these
spots so you had pre identified this LZ
prior to is that correct at that point
we were working with Covey at during the
briefing we give out the officials of L
Z's you know the primary secondary
alternate and and that would go to
Saigon then we whisper in his ear find
something else because we knew this air
was corrupt and then so by finding
something else you're basically just
looking for a clearing of some kind
within that within that target and
usually be somewheres else they go
somewheres where Saigon the leak there
wouldn't get the word back because we
had that one target we went in with the
bomb the LZ was literally wired in a top
sheet cou already had wire already with
a 500 pounder so we were beginning to do
that much more often then could we had
good create coffees they knew what we
did to the Capitol the Cubbies fly the
area of operations before you inserted
on the a before or anything like that
well during the day up they would just
fly over it sure where they take
pictures or anything no no usually they
would just do a VR visual reconnaissance
and they would try to be subtle about
like an early 60 we always flew a visual
we cost us prior to the mission the NVA
is not stupid if they see a bird dog
flying over targeted they figure well
pretty soon we're gonna get visitors and
sure enough so I gave them time to get
ready so we basically cut out the VRS on
our part and then when cub you go out
you know a lot of guys
flying they're more familiar with the VR
with a helicopter
oh no no Luzi with a South Vietnamese
Air Force they'd have a little oh one
just like from World War two the one
from the battle from the balls where
Henry Fonda's up here in the right seat
and the pilots got this little cub Piper
Cubs 80 miles an hour at the top speed
downhill yeah yeah and that's what and
so that would be most of our be ours but
then by Christmas we pretty much cut
that out and that's just because they
were they that was given away you know
we used to ride on logistics air and
kind of move the logistics there a
little bit to go over an area that we
were going over so no one would know
that we were in there that we were
taking pictures you know like just
logistics air just an aircraft flying
somewhere they'd go in a straight line
they wouldn't
they're just veer off a little bit so we
could see what we wanted to see sure
and then also did the fake gal fake
inserts sometimes they didn't have
enough fuel to do a lot fake inserts but
they had a device called the Nightingale
where they would go in sort of
Nightingale off and pull the detonator
on it and it was sound like a fire fight
so that would have all that commotion
and then they would jump up go to a
second LZ and put us in at down south we
were with the the Green Hornet's they
they really had a cold because it was
flat down up down up so at the NVA were
trying to guess which of the three or
four touchdowns where we were they were
really busy got it going back to the
book as the chopper neared the jungle
floor Bubba and I executed our first
standard operating procedure which was
checking the LZ for trip wires or booby
traps while the rest of the team
searched the surrounding jungle for any
signs of trouble after giving the
all-clear the team was out the doors and
on the ground before the skids firmly
touched down how long would you hover
there and look at the LZ for oh not long
like a matter of 10 seconds as we go in
goes down get out sure yeah we used to
just jump out lay down like the
helicopter would just touch them take
off if we would just jump out lay down
right there we wouldn't move
away from it just jump out lay down
modern-day version of touch-and-go yeah
we quickly headed to the wood line and
set up a provisional perimeter where we
could wait and listen when again we saw
and heard nothing suspicious we burrow
deeper into the jungle where as both
denser and darker like some furtive
predatory animal we were looking to hide
ourselves after ten minutes of no
threatening sounds or movements i
radioed covey and gave him the message
he had been waiting to hear team okay he
and others could take up breathing again
at least for the time being
the deeper we moved in the deeper we
moved the darker and more claustrophobic
things became moving through the foliage
was an excruciating ly slow and painful
process with sweat stinging one's eyes
bugs crawling and feasting upon exposed
skin and visibility cut to mere feet it
could be also be disorienting especially
when the maps we were given were so
useless and here was RT Idaho looking
for fuel lines some bright-eyed Covey
Rider had spotted and directed
airstrikes against intelligence reports
said there was a second pipeline in this
AO as well regardless of how many any
pipeline we found we were going to
destroy what would the map well you have
one to fifty maps is that what you had
yeah one to fifty thousand right but
they would cut out from the big map they
would cut out like a ten by ten or
twelve by twelve square mm-hmm so that
if we were killed they came across the
map to be no other intel on separate at
one target area that we were on the
ground now I've gone into triple-canopy
jungle before with what year has seen a
1 to 24 map they're basically more
detailed than us they're twice as
detailed they're pretty good but wonder
50s are not that accurate no then move
ahead I want to argue where they had
forgotten a mountain and we're on a
mountain we're getting ready to go down
to go over and we look at it it's like
hey they forgot one really could stretch
your mission out when you're in Triple
Canopy
claustrophobic you use that word
claustrophobic quite a bit in this
section is this jungle just tight very
yeah because again sometimes you had to
keep sight on the guy in front of you as
you moved because you just become
separated so easily because of the dense
vegetation of course a lot of times our
Vietnamese were shorter they get through
a cricket we would be down on our knees
and I'd be I wore out more pants
crawling through the jungle I know I saw
a picture I was looking at the pictures
in the books I saw a picture one of the
indigenous that some of those guys were
really small oh yeah really small 98
pounds soaking wet
but 50 pounds of heart that's awesome
all right going back to the book but I
had more immediate and pressing concerns
the adrenaline rush that always
accompanied an insertion had pretty much
worn off and another characteristic
sensation had begun to take its place it
was a feeling of familiarity and comfort
combined with an eerie sense of
foreboding both were a product of
experience I was comfortable because I
was surrounded by extraordinary
well-trained and fiercely devoted team
that knew what it was doing yet we also
had stepped in enough accidental shit
and had encountered so many hostile
enemy units that it was impossible to
not feel serious anxiety in fact I
figured that when I stopped being scared
shitless I would be on my way to buying
the farm cockiness had cost more than
one life so you still you get that
little mixed feeling of comfort but fear
and anxiety at the same time yes
you know you think the whole adrenalin
of the you know how it is the asserted
you're just pumped and at some point you
get off you get on the ground because
you guys would hit so many times you
would insert and immediately get
contacted a lot of times yeah so once be
amped up going in and then when there's
nothing there that starts to fade yeah
then you finally get on the grass like
Oh at last for on the ground now let's
get on with the mission
worry about the trackers
get moving but let's also stay cognizant
to keep our situational awareness tight
and that you know this is a one of the
reasons I highlighted this section is
you know just this is something that you
know what we talked about complacency
all the time I know there was a boy in
the Marine Corps units we were with the
three eighth in Ramadi they had a bed a
sign that signs around their compound
complacency kills yeah for sure but this
idea of you know I also talk to young
military guys young seals that you know
they're they're scared of this they're
scared that's like I was so him good you
know you should you should be afraid you
cuz if you're afraid you're gonna
prepare more you're gonna train harder
you're gonna you're not gonna cut any
corners you're not gonna get complacent
and that's the same thing that you're
saying here is you'd seen cockiness cost
people their lives because they think oh
we can just get away with whatever yeah
if you're not scared I'm scared of you
really yeah yeah and then you have to
overcome that though because you can't
let that get get controlling you we were
talking before we started recording we
were talking about a guy that was in a
firefight there was one guy that didn't
fire a shot stayed curled up in a ball
praying yeah that's when that's when
fear is not good not your friend
your guys wanted to shoot him so you got
to balance that you got to be you got to
have the fear you got to feel it but you
got to deal with it
correct we had compasses so we knew the
general direction we were headed which
was to the north west away from the LZ
we had been working away slowly through
the underbrush for about an hour when
suddenly we heard an explosion behind us
it had to have been the Claymore Bubba
rigged to go off of anyone tried to
follow us off the LZ its detonation
singled signaled a profound change in
the situation the hunters were about to
become the hunted in the jungle there
are almost always animal noises of some
kind
and these suddenly fell silent in the
quiet we could hear some distressing
sounds to the west sounds that were not
of a jungle
kind but those of men on the move we
were not alone welcome to the jungle
baby yes indeed that how do you know
that the claymores that you rigged
weren't set off by some kind of monkey
or whatever some kind of animal
he has rigged them a certain way that
that was unlikely the way the way Bubba
and and the Frenchman later would do it
and Lin they would put it in an area
where it would be easiest for the
trackers to follow and so he's based on
human nature you're gonna go through the
stick part you're gonna go where it's
easier to travel and it could have been
an animal but basically it's an envier
animal yeah you know yeah the
coincidence would be too much and the
chances are it's just NVA yeah
and if it is a monkey as opposed to an
NVA we're happy but we'll find that out
within the next couple of hours on the
other hand let's get ready yeah
and this so that when there was when
there was enemy moving in the jungle the
animals would stop making noises it all
depends how clothes he wore but yes law
thoughts that's why the most important
thing in the jungle was listening yeah I
mean 10 and 10 sounds pretty extreme but
it really gives you time to hear what's
going on because you lot of time you
can't see that's the best sense in the
jungle and like I said I've I've been in
Triple Canopy and we've found patrolling
triple-canopy and you can hit by monkeys
too right yeah yeah yeah we had monkeys
freak us out but that the sense just so
people can understand you can only see
in that thick jungle sometimes you can
only see five feet sure five or ten feet
at the most and so you patrol for ten
minutes and then you just stop everyone
is quiet and you listen to see if
anyone's following you to see if there's
any other movement out there that's what
you're doing sure I mean and it's so
thick that if I'm behind a point man or
sometimes it would be the point man with
Sal and myself why would never see the
appointment I would just keep an eye on
Sal and the guy behind me would just be
on my backpack
I wouldn't I couldn't tell you where the
point man was I just follow sounds the
vegetation was that thick a lot of times
again I'm depending on the Vietnamese
cuz they know they need a jungle better
than me how come the animals would stop
making noise would the animal stop
making noise when you would patrol I
would assume
but once we settle down then things
would come back to normal aha
so when you stop moving then the sounds
would escalate and if he didn't after
ten minutes you go the pucker factor
tightens up too little bit more I
immediately signaled Fogg who is on
point to head north this would take us
up a hill that dominated our right flank
that climb was pretty severe which was
good and bad news while it made the
going rough it also meant we were
gaining some genuine high ground and
high ground is the preferred position
when it comes to defense the steepness
also meant the enemy would have to work
as hard as we were I couldn't tell how
close the NVA trackers were or how many
of them were headed our way but I knew
if push came to shove I wanted to be
looking down on them always take the
high ground
always that's just military maxim and
you know I I will actually say you take
the moral high ground as well take the
high ground is gonna take you amen
when we reach the hilltop just as dark
clouds unleashed a torrent of rain while
bubble and sow began setting out a
perimeter of claymores I can't contact
Covey and appraised him of the situation
namely that it didn't look good and that
we might be calling for an immediate
extraction before nightfall do you guys
speak at all only only minimal because
most of you handsome this is everything
else just I usually you'd have to
whisper near yeah but if we we just
avoided as much as we could but
something like this just so people
understand something like this you're on
Patrol you're not saying anything you
head up the hill you don't say anything
you get to perimeter you give the
perimeter signal you don't say anything
and
knows what to do when you're in there
you could go days out in the field
without talking oh yeah absolutely
because what the training is posse got
the visual with the person that you're
signaling mm-hmm like in my case if I'm
behind fucked at the point man I'm
telling him what to do and I'll turn
around tell the guy behind me same
signals and then we go yeah
while I was talking to Covey sow who had
moved north to set out his Claymore
suddenly opened fire on full automatic a
sure sign we had visitors this was
immediately confirmed when heavy ak-47
fire ripped out of the jungle in
response in less than five seconds the
well-practiced sow had fired off all 18
rounds in his car 15 set off the
claymores and reloaded his weapon while
falling back to join the rest of the
team that's legit right there Sal was
making things happen
he was demand would you guys you guys be
trained in these immediate action drills
mag changes I mean everything that we do
right you guys can't drill that stuff
every drill and drill and drill if we're
in camp we go down often and just
particularly in the beginning to June my
first couple months whenever every day
hundred surrounds and when this happens
these guys are called the enemy is
covary close to you because you can at
least know that they're there they gotta
be what 15 20 maybe 30 meters away and
in that case here I forget how close
they weren't that far for Sal to blow
his Claymore and take ar-15 and reload
and do it one more time back to the book
cover you'd heard the background shots
and explosions so he was not overly
surprised when I stated the obvious we
had a prairie fire emergency in progress
and we wanted out ASAP the mission was
over if the fuel lines would have to
wait until another day the focus now
became saving our asses and to this end
every air sab air asset within striking
distance would immediately be vectored
to our target area the odds would soon
turn if not necessarily in our favor
very decidedly against the enemy arty
Idaho might not make it out alive
but neither would the end
you guys had some serious confidence in
that air power yeah that was our
lifeline I mean a major edge that we had
and whenever we could use it we we use
it because there's only a matter of time
before they would give more bodies there
and we had teams that had been overrun
and 67-68 so we knew the potential for
things that go really wrong and that was
one of the things I could neutralize
demand power when I had the enemy has so
many troops did teams ever get overrun
while they had air power oh sure
sadly yes yeah oh yeah they would just
keep coming this silver the Medal of
Honor recipients fred's apatow ski
Robert Howard SF on missions and they
were directing air power stills got
overrun that's all part of the horror of
being on the ground it gets they really
determined foe so even though you have
confidence in your air power you know
there's limitations and if things really
go bad that air power is not going to be
able to deceive you correct again it's
time weather and where are you in the
jungle and the Triple Canopy if you're
in Triple Canopy all you could do is
maybe gun runs and you're not even sure
how effective it'll be but at least you
get their attention going back to the
book call King bees call King bees
beaucoup VC beaucoup VC it was clear sow
and I shared similar appraisal of our
situation and the same thoughts about
what needed to be done the only hitch
was how to pull it off well with
darkness approaching a storm raging and
no helicopters anywhere near us I didn't
want to add to either sounds or the
team's angst so I didn't share my
misgivings instead I gave Covey the
direction and probable distance we'd
moved from the LZ and told them I was
about to throw two yellow smoke grenades
to marco location i threw two hoping
some of the smoke would somehow travel
up through the
thick vegetation and into the clear
where Covey could see it
Covey had good and bad news he thought
he had our location but he doubted
seriously if he could get extraction
helicopters to us before nightfall not
good not good at all we now had
confirmed enemy north and south of us
and they were closing in South
frantically signaled Bubba to set off
from the south facing claymores when
Bubba hesitated for a second I could
hear Hsiao his coat of crocodile VC how
do you say that taka dal Kaka Dalvi see
him use for kill do ma which is
Vietnamese for mother motherfuckers as
the claymores erupted Sal pulled the pin
on a fragmentation grenade and lobbed it
into the boiling dust and smoke even as
even more enemy troops came up the slope
with my ears ringing from the blasts I
thought I heard additional movement to
the east but I couldn't be sure because
the NVA had abandoned any pretense of
stealth I soon verified they were coming
from that flank as well and there were
lots of them as these unseen forces
maneuvered in for the kill the jungle
took on its most terrifying and
claustrophobic reality not a friendly
place in the very best of circumstances
it was now about the worst place in the
world to be again that claustrophobic
sense can you see can you see the sky in
this Triple Canopy depends sometimes you
can see it like glimpses of it or like
to be a little opening so he was able to
see the smoke sometimes you pop a yellow
smoke which is bright and it wouldn't
even be able to get through everyone was
cutting loose as fast as he could an
effort to suppress the enemy's fire and
drive him back Tuan had managed to find
some narrow openings in the vegetation
and was shooting rounds with his m79
grenade launcher and suddenly the jungle
went silent as if someone had thrown a
switch or hit it hit the mute button
the only sounds were the metallic clicks
as both Artie Idaho and the NVA locked
fresh magazines into their weapons the
fight was far from over
in fact the party was just getting
started and we were simply changing
records for the next dance with death
the jungle again erupted with deafening
roar of gunfire
so that's sketchy that's got to be a
horrifying feeling boom goes quiet
everyone dumps their mags there's that
moment of silence and in that silence
are you here as reload out well and you
know too when when that happens how when
your Adrenaline's pumping when you're
here your time frame has expanded mm-hmm
so now instead of like you read it
that's how quick it is bam bam you're
saying but now I mean the adrenaline it
feels like it slow down you can feel the
magazine coming out you hear that click
everybody else is ramming them in come
on boys let's come down on this first
and our guys one with all the noise I
had to shove the radio handset damn near
inside my ear to hear what Covey was
trying to tell me the good news bad news
routine continued the good news was that
some of the yellow smoke had finally
made its way to where come he could see
it but the bad news was we were nowhere
near the nlz he wanted to know if we
could fight our way back to where we had
been inserted negative I yelled as fuck
Bubba and HAP all opened up on some NVA
who had managed to sneak up from the
south there were green tracers whizzing
all around me Covey would have to wait
and that's another good point because in
this war the enemy almost always had
green tracers always okay yeah for us
the enemy didn't always have green a
gret they in fact most of time well a
lot of times I had red because they had
well no kidding yeah so what they
learned a lesson yeah so it was it you
know they just they got their ammo from
all different sources and so it wasn't
just this there wasn't just hey they're
green and we're red it was mostly red
some green occasionally but wow yeah
yeah
after helping repel the attack I got
back on the radio to impress upon Covey
the direness of our straights but of
course he already knew that so in his
calm voice which could drive a 1:02
murder he said we don't have a lot of
time no shit the only chance we have is
about a hundred meters north by
northeast from your location there's a
small hole in the roof and we might be
able to get strings down to you he
inquired if we had much activity to our
north it depended I thought on what you
meant by much an activity I reminded him
that North was where the whole shooting
match got started and while the unit
while I fought we had pretty much taken
that group of NVA out of action I
couldn't be sure when I finished he said
don't worry I have a pair of a1 E's on
station and I'll have the leader make a
gun run and then give and then have his
wingman follow with 500-pounders before
I could say Roger that the first sky
Raider roared across our northern
perimeter his 20 millimeter cannons
blazing away as woodchips dust and
debris filled the air the members of RTI
Idaho did not need to be told what to do
we kissed Mother Earth and pressed
against her body for all we were worth
in the brief quiet that followed
I told Bubba to prepare some explosives
just in case we needed to cut down trees
at the extraction point I told Sal we
needed to head north as that was our
only chance for escape no one looked
happy with this news particularly not
Sal who had finished who had seen
firsthand what was waiting in that
direction about this time the second sky
Raider appeared and released its load of
500-pound bombs they were so close that
the concussions bounced us like jumping
beans and this is all based on the
yellow smoke that you'd thrown five
minutes ago or eight minutes ago right
there looking at a massive weight this
is another thing it's hard to understand
it's hard for me nurse and I was
memorize a radio man when I was a new
guy and we were out in the desert and we
were trying to call in helicopters to
come pick us up
and it's me call them in it's not we as
me I'm sitting there on the radio trying
to call in these helicopters
and I got my air panel out and we're in
the desert
this isn't Tripucka this is the desert
and these helicopters can't see me
they're not far they're not at altitude
they're probably five hundred to five
hundred meters away are they doing that
for the earth or they're looking for us
they're kind of they know we're in the
general area and they're looking for us
and I'm sitting there with a signal
panel like trying to get their attention
and what you don't realize is that
there's you know you you're seeing this
helicopter it's so obvious I mean you'd
think there's no possible way that they
can't see you'd think there's no pop we
got us a 16-man seal platoon out there
I'm waving around a piece of fluorescent
orange we're the only human beings in
this desert and they can't see us and
now you're and the reason they can't see
us is because they're looking everywhere
they're looking they're looking at
whatever what how many square miles that
into an ocean yeah yeah they can see all
this space and so it takes him a while
you know finally I get him to say I
think I pop this I think I propped a
smoke and they didn't see the smoke and
then I popped another smoke and so that
I can't imagine these guys are coming in
hot
dropping bombs based on where the cut
not even him but where the covey saw
smoke five minutes ago
yeah we may have popped another smoke in
there somewhere and also I know that I
had talked to cubby okay here's our
smoke north of us and he knew they had
we had a lot of octane north and south
and he forgot about maybe we won't get
it from the east but for talked about
trying to get to the north that's why he
he came across the northern so he knew
basically where we were and he came in
at cost of five hundred pounds were able
to get through the jungle and impact on
the ground and those things rocked you
guys oh yeah
one of those happy pings good times I
guess tilt alright with the a1e activity
to occupy us we had momentarily taken
our attention away from our southern
flank and now a wave of NVA hit us from
that direction everyone responded with
automatic fire and Bubba and I lob some
grenades down the slope
I am from Covey of the attack and told
him that when I gave the word and the
team moved to the north I wanted more a
one he runs to our South in my heart of
hearts I also wanted more runs to the
north but we didn't have time for that
we had to get out while the getting was
good
the next NVA wave could be the one to
overrun us as Bubba finished preparing
explosives HAP and I continued rolling
grenades downhill toward the enemy sow
and fook covered Tuan with car 15 fire
as he set up a claymore facing south and
covered it with leaves a little parting
gift for our friends the race was on I
gave Covey the word and behind us the a1
the a1 ease began bombing the shit out
of whoever was back there fuck angled
back to the north we passed the we
passed bodies of dead NVA soldiers but
we didn't have time to stop and search
them for papers or anything of an
intelligence value we had only one
thought in mind get out it was something
of a miracle that Faulk and sau actually
located the spot Covey had found for us
when we finally looked up toward the
hole itself however it appeared a long
long ways away it was at least a hundred
feet or more and the green tunnel
leading to it was narrow and dangerous
as we were approaching I had seen the
tops of trees being whipped around by
the gusting wind and knew this would
complicate matters even more this was
not going to be an easy exit so you guys
are moving to this thing you're looking
up at the treetops and you see there's
like a heavy wind because I store that's
just weather wind like it's wet it's
windy out and we had weather forecasts
and it might be some problems with the
weather
so here we are as dark and I'm I didn't
tell the geysers I mean yeah I knew that
seeing those trees like that this is
yeah and I was getting late dark I
needed your Nog's
yeah you did I wish you could Adam bro
but when I totally changed this whole
scenario oh yeah cuz the helicopter
because the aircraft too sure because
the aircraft would be oh yeah we got you
yeah we got you locked and we'll just
will you guys can just you know pitch a
tent and the NVA
this still you know the the big motto of
the insurgents right is that they only
fight when they want to and they don't
have to fight if they don't need to and
you don't imagine troops that don't have
to fight just keep coming after you
just keep you're laying waste to them
but they keep coming that must be the
value of capturing you all cross-border
would be so high that they just must
have had serious intent to try and
capture well yeah and then then too you
know you had that propaganda they've
been fed for all those years they really
believed they really believed that like
the French we were there to occupy but
we're just there was combating communism
but then they never heard any of that
stuff and they were dedicated that's
absolutely yes sir
back to the book the envy had not given
up its troops were hot on our tail even
though we had heard Tuan's claim or go
off and had listened to the a1 EES work
them over you had to hand it to the NVA
soldiers they were very tough and
determined I again contacted Covey and
asked for some asked for some Tactical
Air Command air support to our rear and
in a matter of minutes bombs were
falling and cannons were blasting away
I'm sure I was impressed with the
service as the NVA were surprised by how
quickly the ordinance has been delivered
they were learning a lesson the hard way
if a recon team wasn't wiped out in the
first few minutes of the fight
the NVA would pay dearly for the mistake
but more than one NVA unit had
experienced this firsthand so that's
kind of a creek critical few minutes as
long as how long did it take for air to
get on station usually well dependent
everywhere it's been several hours - in
this case we were fortunate to make
contact really early on with Covey who
fortunately had a ones that were within
a few minutes away so there were some
luck involved
very much I mean we didn't we seldom had
that kind of response and layoffs
did you ever pre plan to have coverage
at certain times it would be a special
mission yeah like the ones we put in the
sensors you put him in and you know
you're gonna have any ground for two or
three hours he booked the times had the
SS set so we have to go or something
happens in between being eating come in
but most of the time were these were
these aircraft necessarily briefed on
the mission itself so that we they know
coming in hey this is the ail that
they're working over these guys just
coming are they were just they were just
random pilots OB both they had specific
a1 units in the air force in that time
frame that were specifically there for
SOG missions and SAR search and rescue
up north for any downed pilots so they
were very much attuned to our people
working with con tomb and with us up
north so they knew everything was in the
prairie fire AO sometimes when you like
when we're in Echo for our first contact
was with a fighter jet that heard the
Herc ten beeper and responded to that so
and other missions another aircraft
would hear it and they would if they had
ordnance then we had to you know get the
Miri get them located to find us and
then bring in the Ordnance well he put
the call out to get the Covey or the
hillsborough or moonbeam let them know
they had a tactical emergency going on
and you're doing all that on the radio
while you're still fighting yeah we had
had to spend a few rounds here lighten
the load all right Bubba
sau and fuck had been busy placing
explosive charges on trees while hep and
Tuan set out claymores facing south I
couldn't help but shake my head in
wonder at HAP in a dark jungle with
night approaching he still had his
ever-present sunglasses we blew the
charges around the trees and they were
cut clean but the dense jungle refused
to let them fall we had not succeeded in
making the hole any bigger so we just
have to hope the rescue ships could
manage to drop the ropes down to us and
then pray the ropes were long enough so
you're trying to make that hole in the
jungle a little bit bigger like what
diameter is this hole that you're
looking at oh this is like 10 meters is
it not not you know it's a good question
maybe 2030 meters okay at the most but
there's treason ya know it's Lisa it's a
little bit more open as opposed to just
Triple Canopy enclosed where you're just
completely we could see skylight you can
literally see the sky mm-hmm but and
then you try and blow some of the trees
but they don't even fall down because
it's too much jungle - mines yeah yes
exactly doesn't even help didn't help
good times
instead of frustration we tried to blow
up some palm trees or actually was Lafe
Leif's
platoon tried to blow up some palm trees
that were obstructing their view you
know overwatch position right and they
blew up they said they said so many
charges on these palm trees it was
embarrassing
I never launched I got read no they
weren't they didn't budge no I got
embarrassed I'm sitting there telling
the the battalion commander he's saying
what I'm saying hey sir there's gonna be
another controlled debt and boom and
then so there's gonna be another control
tent and then boom and then so there's
gonna be another control bet and then
BOOM he said what are they doing I said
- trying to get rid of some bomb trees
don't worry about it you know what sir
we're just gonna leave those palm trees
yeah the score right now is palm trees
three seals zero yeah that's what
happened
know those palm trees are hard resilient
thick alright back to the book with the
helicopters on their final approach I
threw out another smoke grenade to mark
our location and the rest of the team
began firing at the NVA who had again
pressed in on us we could barely make
out make out their shadows but they were
definitely out there as evidenced by the
green tracer rounds flying towards us
Covey hadn't been able to see my smoke
so he asked for a pen flare when I tried
to fire it up through the trees it
struck a limb and bounced back being
desperate I told Covey Oh is gonna shoot
three tracer rounds red tracer rounds up
through the hole and before he could
scream no I had pulled the trigger on my
car fifteen I immediately realized what
a dangerous move it was as I saw him
pass overhead in case there was any
doubt in my mind Covey took the time to
let me know in no uncertain terms how
stupid I was I believe the expressions
dumb asked and shit-for-brains came into
play loudly so you're in this situation
he still took the time to call you
shit-for-brains yeah no you're about to
die prize oh yeah and you know I was
thinking I've never fought in
Afghanistan I don't know what they
hadn't know if they saw a lot of more
green tracers over there off to ask some
of my buddies and never really thought
about that so that's a that was that
just like the normal little pencil flare
yes a little trigger thing you crack
single right like a 22 round that fires
up it's a tracer yes you know it didn't
penetrate through so you decide you're
just gonna fire some compounds but fuck
my tracers but they saw him right they
did yeah so hey one four till just
before the rescue choppers attempted to
hover and drop the ropes I told Covey I
wanted the gunships that accompanied
them to work over the area around us
particularly to the south I wanted the
NVA to be either dead wounded or with
their heads buried in the ground when we
tried to make our escape the muskets the
men from the 176 assault helicopter
company immediately went to work with
their 2.75 inch rockets and their
Gatling like many guns multi-barreled
weapons that could pump 6,000 rounds of
six to a minute as the last rocket hit
and exploded behind us
the first 101st Airborne Division slick
appeared over the hole in the jungle
roof and dropped sandbags with ropes
attached to them the helicopter was so
high up it looked like a toy and even
its powerful rotor wash couldn't reach
us
I could tell he wasn't being buffeted by
the wind but he'd somehow managed to
hold steady over the opening one of the
sandbags attached to the rope had a
strobe light attached to it and we
watched it bounce off the limbs as it
fell toward us you guys I guess they
hadn't invented the jungle penetrator
yet they has but not on you ease they
had them on the HH threes and the mean
giant yes for those that don't know it's
like a big metal yeah jungle penetrator
it's a big metal kind of spear almost
spear man that was still cable to hook
to a crane and it just drops down and
that weight and it's well shaped as
opposed to just a random sandbag it
bouncing here and so this thing was hot
this thing must have been like 150 feet
up yeah they had the longest ropes in
there surprise even got down to us back
to the book while we kept an eye on the
ropes descending through the trees the
NVA mounted a desperate last charge
towards us Tuan and hep triggered their
K claymores and the rest of us opened up
with all we had somehow in the midst of
all the tumultuous activity the four
ended had managed to rig themselves a
Swiss seat using the six foot long
pieces of rope we carried just for that
purpose
bub and I now tried to do the same but
it wasn't easy to wrap a rope around my
waist pass it between my legs and then
finish tying it off on the right hip
while under fire but we managed to do it
while the in Dajjal doff the enemy and
began to hook up for the lift out you
guys ever think about using some kind of
pre-rigged like sid harness or something
they they were developing those at a
time they upgrade they had like the
McGuire rig which is just basically a
thick material that you could sit in
and then later they came out with the
rigs Captagon there but it was a an
outfit where you had your heart's
built-in she had the web gear with the
harness so when they came down he just
hopefully in clicking you ready good I'd
be thinking about that stay free when I
when I found this you credit AIA story
seat
yeah that's awesome we were getting low
on ammunition grenades and claymores if
we didn't make it out it was gonna be a
very long night in fact I wasn't sure we
could I wasn't sure if we could survive
the night no matter what kind of air
support managed to reach us it was Now
or Never Sal and Fock located three of
the four ropes and it attached
themselves to one of them using snap
links when I asked Covey if the chopper
could lift us all out at once he replied
no way it's going to take two lifts no
way is exactly what I thought in return
there was no way we had enough time for
two attempts there was no way I was
going to split the team either all six
of us were going out together on four
ropes or we were going to die together
trying call it camaraderie or fear but I
was not going to leave anyone myself
included on the ground for a minute
longer than necessary
I had heard all the horror stories I
needed to about what could result in and
I didn't want to be the subject of some
gruesome tale around the bar at fo b1 I
suddenly had a bright idea and asked Bob
if he still had the Claymore with the
white phosphorus grenade taped to its
front when he nodded yes I told him to
strap it as high as he could as high as
he could reach on a nearby tree facing
south he gave me his best are you out of
your fucking mind look because he knew
at that proximity the back blast would
kill us all when we set it off so he
hesitated and I had to order him to do
it once he finished the remaining two
little people paired up and hooked
themselves on into one of the ropes
while Bubba and I each took one of the
remaining two I wanted to balance out
the weight distribution by having me on
one side of the helicopter and Bubba on
the other but it was impossible to tell
for sure which ropes went where so I
took a wild
and hope for the best best using the
barrel of my m79 to shield the flash
from the NVA I used a strobe light to
signal the chopper to begin to lift to
begin lifting us out did the chopper
have enough power
would we be dragged through the trees
would the NVA manage to shoot one or all
of us out of our saddles we were about
to find out as the ropes became taut
fire gunfire erupted from the West
Southfork and I returned fire but our
bodies blocked the others line of sight
so they watched in frustration because
my rope was longer than the other three
I was the last to leave the ground this
also gave me the additional seconds I
needed to reload my empty car 15 twice
things were happening very fast almost
too fast and my bright idea demanded
perfect timing as we started up Bubba
reached out and ignited the delay flues
on the delay fuse on the last Claymore
the one he'd fastened to the tree with
my feet dangling in the air I fired
around for my m79 still gaining altitude
I then pulled the pins on two hand
grenades and tossed them down onto the
ground at about the same time the
Claymore went off the back blast blew
under us but we could still feel its
power and heat the phosphorous was like
a giant flash bulb going off and that
frozen instant of illumination I could
finally see the faces of my enemy they
were hurting but still advancing with
its engine screaming the Huey somehow
came up with the power it needed it was
agonizingly slow going and we had to
push our way through some branches but
we were not being dragged through them
we were being lifted straight up the NVA
continued to fire at us and I had the
unsettling impression that tracer rounds
were passing between my legs and a
sensation that will give any man pause
for thought the team fired back on full
automatic and we threw the last of our
grenades like two fiercely demented and
determined beasts
the NVA and Artie Idaho remain locked in
battle to the bitter end
as we finally cleared the trees I
immediately called Covey and confessed
our little deception the team is out the
whole team is out I screamed into the
handset we came out together do not send
in a second helicopter I repeat no
second chopper the muskets rolled in and
pulverized the ground we had just left
the a1 es were right behind them and as
the muffled explosion and light flashes
reached me I found myself feeling a
little sorry for the NVA troops down
there they were valiant and dedicated
soldiers they would have - they would
have been a credit a credit to any army
those left alive would no doubt have
some stories to tell but I doubted they
would ever admit that a six-man team had
held them at bay for so long and then
escaped their most determined efforts to
wipe them out as for RT Idaho we were
simply happy to be alive not something I
would have bet on a short while earlier
oh yeah oh yeah and we were we were
lucky too because of the were more lucky
than that I mean we we used up a whole
lot of luck on that one but you know is
we're lucky because we were still
relatively high not like the big Peaks
and deeper into layoffs and so the
helicopter was able to pull us out if
that had been in the middle of the day
and with jungle heat and the heat of the
day he never would have been able to
have six of us out but we weighed all
that and I didn't listen to cubby just
rolled the dice cuz it was so dark at
that point so oh yeah the recon guide
smiled on us one more time so when you
when you once you got pulled out would
they just look for a clearing somewhere
to set down get you guys in the
helicopter for real no that's the part
that support day just froze your balls
off
because with the Swiss seat out in the
rope you just everything goes numb yeah
and so because it was dark particularly
they want to make sure they wherever
they put us down was going to be
somewhere in South Vietnam so we were in
the air I just forget how long and they
finally set us down but you can't walk
you just you like to like a cripple for
a five-minute clip yeah on clip you
can't flip so they so they didn't really
care about your comfort no and we end we
didn't complain too much but you here
you go you're all sweaty
yeah and you know how it is we fight
five minutes later you're 5,000 feet
which is cold people forget how cold it
is at 5,000 feet yeah you're freezing
yeah especially because you're soaking
wet
yeah any feeling it's 80 miles an hour
so yeah 80 mile an hour wind yeah all
that - yeah this is just I mean this is
just crazy it's absolutely crazy and
this was just over and over again now
you know I spent a lot of time on the
books on the last couple podcasts I
wanted to I wanted to kind of just ask
you a couple questions get your thoughts
on some stuff and it's also another way
you might have to come back again but I
got saga Chronicles here I read that
outstanding book you know this is the
song chronicles real quick talks about a
big operation that that would that took
place that you weren't on but you got
really good descriptions and talked to
people
operation tailwind that's another one
where helicopters are getting shot down
I mean it's completely completely insane
yeah and and no no ordinary hillock
these are the C's 53's
Delta models yeah the biggest Marine
Corps had and they took out two of those
left one really banged up yeah and when
they inserted they still they had three
WS on their assertion but they had to
get in for that to take the pressure off
of the CIA operation that was the
mission September 1970 yeah that's so
that's operation tailing operation
tailwind and that that
chronicles Volume one and I hope there's
gonna be about 30 more volumes I'm gonna
be working on it the model that Anna and
I came up with is that we're gonna write
till we die I like it could there's so
many socks there is that there have been
told you could we couldn't tell and some
of her guys I mean even when I a fellow
recon guy talked to him it's like
pulling information I was sure you've
run into that with your people they
they're not they're not inclined to talk
well yeah and they're modest
that's an interesting thing because
people do not the wannabes at the bar
I'm a green beret or I'm a seal and most
of the guys when you know people say
well you should have more guys from tu
bruiser on there you have to have more
guys more seals on the seals that I know
that I would want to have on a lot of
them they're still in or they don't want
to come on they won't say a word
yeah there's they're like hey I'm good
you know and then obviously I got a lot
of my friends that that do come on and
it gets great when they come on but yeah
a lot of guys are still doing it you
know and so hey that's the way it is I
want once those guys retire and I do
have some friends that are retiring soon
and they're becoming on so that's pretty
awesome
oh yeah but um yes so the SOG Chronicles
you you've like I said hopefully there's
30 volumes of that right now there's
just one we're gonna try to turn across
the fence and on the ground into audio
books that's awesome that's our project
right now and then as soon as we're done
with that to commence with volume 2 and
we got a couple of stories there well
the one that we talked about it on the
ground the August 23rd attack we've had
a lot more research we had this gal
who's a that she was an MI and she has
pulled out more information as we're
gonna pull the whole thing together for
the Hopi the most detailed story tonight
because of such a tragic yet heroic
night for the people that were there on
the ground and I and Larry tremble up on
Marble Mountain yeah so we have that a
couple other stories many other stories
but there's the other one one of our
guys went in for a bright light and they
got shot out in a f4 crashed as it was
crashing it hit three separate hilt
coming to rest on a third one they got
to the second Hill and it got shot out
he went back 25 years later he became a
doctor on his own money spent $70,000 to
go back to Cambodia to try to find that
f4 just not as conscience they got in
got to the site and were run off by
bandits he went back now would be two
years ago with DPA a and DPA a was
working on the second hill where the jet
was on the third hills he's he able to
go in and give them direct sighting as
to where to dig so they're still working
and he was on the ground digging things
out with these guys that's gonna be in
that book yeah yeah so check out that
book to SOG chronicles your training how
ready do you think you were when you got
to Vietnam how ready for you for what
you were about to encounter well a lot
better than the guys that went through
just basic training and advanced
infantry training and I'm sure that
commissioning units had in-country
training our in-country training was was
good he worked we you know we practice
calling in spooky worked with the
helicopters told about the dangers and
working with the little people to
history as well as some of the do's and
don'ts about working with South
Vietnamese and I thought that was good
but then to just know a camp Duty which
is I think all that was geared for the
eight camps mmm
SOG was just in another level and that's
why we always talked so people like Pat
walk in spite of parks John McGovern
dick gross Deaver the senior East 7th or
east sixes in camp all of whom had run
at night us green guys would talk to him
particularly after missing and then we
talk to each other you know John Walton
came back from a target and where Tom
Cunningham's leg was blown off one of
those little people it's got shot four
times in captain tin who saved us in
October pulled them out
August and we talked right away that
night well what did you learn and and
always be just back and forth to try to
get any sense of what happened when
anything you could do to give us
anything for another edge on the field
and meanwhile we're getting the Intel
reports we knew Bello teams have been
wiped out and Intel reports about the
sappers so y'all balanced it out and
just key thing was comma so an answer to
your question SOG was so different
a lot of both innovative the things we
were doing there were these strings that
was all things that you used today
really advanced it no no fast ropes that
was another dimension of another war so
we're working at the firepower working
with the air assets and new weapons but
it was all I could experimental things
learn as you go try take was best and
looking in black blow yourself up in an
ambush that's what good luck to make
sure it really works did you when you
were calling for fire so I don't know if
you know this but now it's like a school
you go to you you go to joint tactical
inter controller school and that's sort
of your specialty is calling for fire
calling right bombs but you just you
trained in country to learn how to do it
yes and again we talked to that's where
we talked to spider and pat walk is
specifically and so that was the that
was more important than actually going
out pop and smoke and having a gun run
there was learning how to do it the
right way
now you're in a box and you never have a
gun run go across you hit be in front
you know your front to left southeast
and you direct it that way and how many
inches I mean how many feet of yards
from your perimeter how many meters and
that applied when we got to the field
because once we were up at feu by we
didn't practice airstrikes once we're on
the ground we did it but it did it with
confidence thanks to Spyder walkins and
John McGovern particularly they sat with
the green guys at night and made us you
know understand that and we had a couple
cases where people made mistakes and
teams got hit and lost people
they had a they were bringing some
people where our body count was so low
that they were bringing in people from
other units and they were coming cocky
and when once they got on the ground
they were just maybe a little too cocky
and have listened to little lessons and
some of the teams would let the other
people carry their I carried a radio and
we had one team young guy came in and
called airstrike on his own team they
came with a gun ran right across the
team's ro n and it's like that you know
so III that does not surprise me at all
I mean when I'm listening to or reading
your books the fact that you guys were
doing that the you can obviously had a
massive amount of skill to not have that
happen cuz like I said these guys are
looking at a jungle canopy they looking
at some random bit of smoke that came
out and yet you're directing fire based
on that it's it's it's awesome but I
could see where somebody could easily
you know make a mistake you know you
give the wrong direction you you know
you look at your compass is spinning the
wrong way you know it's could close to
your weapon you got your cardinal
directions I mean there's so many things
that could go wrong that and yeah and
yet you're just doing I mean there's
times we're out there doing gun runs for
for 12 hours straight long time and in
like your case we you had the the unit
that you wanted attacked the building
and you challenged that three times and
the last time you called it off because
it was another unit another SEAL team
well we had that common sense thing on
the ground to where we would direct it
but if there was something that wasn't
quite right you put everything on hold
until you got it right
yeah that's it's weird cuz life and I
wrote extreme ownership and we didn't
really coordinate
stories that we were talking about and
yet there's multiple stories in there
about either blue on blues or potential
bloom blues cuz man in a city like that
with all these different different units
running around all on different radio
frequencies oh yeah and a bunch of enemy
Mujahideen fighters running around in
there too it was blue on blue was a very
real thing and there would be probably
one case of blue on
a day that would happen and maybe one a
week that would get reported you know
but just and I'm not talking more
someone who's shop but like you know
just all of a sudden you're taking
rounds you like where are those coming
from oh that's another unit down there
and for us and for a one opening up on
me exactly exactly so that it would
happen all the time
and that's one thing that was nice about
well for you if not nice but it's less
complicated you're the only friendly
guys out there well you know there was
no friendly fire happening you guys this
us versus them when you got mission
taskings hmm where'd they come from
were they were they coming from up above
were you guys developing targets
yourself where did that how did that
process a happy mix of both the the
chain command for SOG went to saw
headquarters right to the White House
they had somebody from DoD that was
there some I don't serve in general
somebody but that was their mission was
keep an eye on saw so they would send
missions from there that would come to
headquarters to each fo be and then our
immediate action reports that I'll go
back after actually reports would go
back through the chain of command so
they knew what was going on at the White
House there was somebody at the West
that's where we were told and on
occasions if we had a target that we
wanted to do b-52 strike that would go
back to the chain of command and then
get approval on but the the from what
the public knew the public knew we were
bombing I didn't know anything about him
but they didn't even know we were
bombing Laos and Cambodia rekt nothing
there are no reporters in there
there's no communist news network back
then so and the Communists would not
talk about it because they had agreed to
the agreement not having their people
there could they always said hey les I
can't but they're neutral we respect
them lion dogs and we said the same
thing but ours
we just went in with our Recon teams as
opposed to them just going down and
enslaving all the people to work there
work with us help us to open the roads
and you know if we saw indigenous people
we were not open fire on I mean it's
like you're not gonna go ahead to the
local people they don't know any better
just caught in the middle
mm-hmm but the NBA Dave David Tom you
work with us so you die yeah well you
you know and one of the books you're
talking about how the the NVA treated
the ended people they're so horribly
that the end is that you weren't worth I
hated the NVA oh he hated him the these
NVA had raped their women and beat their
wives and just done horrible things to
them and so they were there for they
were there to fight yep and they they
cut nobody any slack I mean America
today particularly our snowflakes don't
know what the soldiers of communism were
really like in the field and it's just
nasty people and that's what we were
fighting mm-hmm and they were dead they
were really dedicated and their their
sense of purpose
because they've been so thoroughly
indoctrinated and they really believe
what they're doing even though they're
working off of propaganda yeah when you
saw them so you would come up with some
of the missions some of the missions
would come down to you majority came
majority came down to you and of course
you know they was had sometimes I think
there would be we got to get a team on
the ground that's why we were going in
primary secondary all think is shot out
eat lunch go back and try again because
they just wanted to get somebody on the
ground and that would just be your s
automatic aerial reconnaissance and
that's because they had something they
wanted to see there something something
like that sometimes whereas three people
would just want to get a team on the
ground so they could be poor to
headquarters at night we have one or two
teams on the ground where do you mean
that they're just wanting to hey look
what we're doing yeah now if shorty guys
are an s3 would deny it and emphatically
but it felt like that yeah her technique
came back and said here's a new target
and they'll pick an LZ for you while
you're flying back to the next target
did you ever what if you what if there
was a mission that you looked at and you
said hey this is dumb
this doesn't make sense well there's
only one - I declined to rant about
Christmastime is 68 I just had a feeling
and a team went in I was worried but
they'd only ground for five days and it
was a dry hole and they came out without
any shots fired or anything so that's
one time I officially turned something
down maybe that's why you had a bad
feeling tell if you knew nothing was
gonna happen it wasn't your kind of
target yeah I want a boring - are you so
if so how did it go when you when you
said no would you say hey look my guys
need rest sorry yeah not this time we
had the right to say no it was found on
yeah but you know they had at that time
we had a couple new teams in camp and
Rodney had came in and he was good one
zero so he went out he came back said
hey you know that target was pretty cool
we stopped a lot dry hole dry hole so
really I had all these feelings man I
was hyperventilating Terrell I figured
we're gonna run it to Ho Chi Minh is and
you know a couple of divisions again for
good luck I hadn't seen a division in a
month no it's like okay but no see and
that kind of showed me how your mental
state of mind - because I really that's
why I believed that and the system was
such that you could turn it down and we
took it for near where you say that's
where you believed you you believe that
it was a bad target I just felt we had
been so lucky and going through the
Christmas Thanksgiving and everything
else that our I just felt our number is
gonna bill didn't know how and I just
said this could be the target
it's an MMA target and those were
particularly dirty of the ones that are
all along the DMZ River west of Vietnam
that went deeper into layoffs and they
were NASA we lost several teams up there
mm-hmm I figured this could be our turn
so buzzer oh no did you ever get that
feeling again not not not enough strong
enough to act on it and I mean they're
carried in the back of my tiny mind just
like you thought you were gonna die you
didn't I had some guys that thought they
were gonna die every time we left the
wire do you know what I mean god bless
him but he's no man this
tonight could be the night man no I'm
not feeling good about this one and
they'd always get their gear on but I'd
say no yeah I always looked at as a good
sign if certain people were scared if
they wouldn't wouldn't have been scared
I would have been nervous because they
were so scared all the time
I think man this must be really
stressful for him yeah I never wrote the
letter like dear Mom and Dad I'm dead
now if you read this letter I'm dead
yeah I know I just felt it hoped that we
somehow get through it and and you're
right about the scare thing you you want
that emotional edge a little fear can go
along it's a great motivator but I
wouldn't I wouldn't go out with a guy if
somebody say hey man I'm not afraid mm
I'm afraid you do you go somebody else I
also used to get the feeling that if you
were scared like that if you were if you
were scared and you were gonna be
hesitant that was gonna be bad sure like
I I was more worried about guys that
were like hesitant or I felt like if
they were hesitant on the battlefield
that would work out bad for them the
guys that I always felt like okay if
someone's aggressive not not not
unafraid and suicidal like that but just
hey oh yeah I'm gonna go do I'm gonna go
we're gonna go kick ass right now I was
felt that was the attitude to have it
was to be aggressive was to be like okay
yeah we're oh you want you got an OP for
us cool we'll go do it now we turn down
ops to there was ops where we looked at
and said man this is not good and this
is a massive amount of risk I mean there
was areas where there was areas where
they would take ie D strikes on vehicles
and like you know and when in a big idea
hits a Humvee everyone dies or oh yeah
three out of five people died or
something like that I mean it's it's
very catastrophic and there was one
target they were looking at for us they
asked us to do and the that was like one
road going in that had multiple big ID
strikes and then they wanted us to they
were asking if we could take out mortar
it was either a mortar team or an ID in
Placer but
we were looking at it and we're that
more does it been launched from we're
all over the place so it was just it was
one of the one of the types of missions
where we looked at and said hey there's
got to be a better way to do this
because us going up there is not going
to be worth it a lot of your misses were
point missions right what do you mean by
that
they give you target get to this point
and wipe it out I would say my first
deployment it was go capture kill bad
guys that was my first deployment to
Iraq we're in Baghdad where that's where
mostly what we were doing the middle of
the night we'd find out what a bad guy
was we'd go get him and that's what my
second deployment in Ramadi mostly what
guys were doing was overwatch sniper
overwatch positions set up in buildings
so that when the bad guys would either
maneuver on friendly forces or they'd be
out doing what they shouldn't be doing
right the guys would take them out so
that's that's pretty much the then
there's all kinds of crap in between
that everything from you know everything
from doing just reconnaissance of areas
to counter mortar types it's just you
know a lot of other a lot of other
things would happen but primarily it was
direct-action missions going out to take
out a target or these sniper overwatch
types but you know we'd be doing big
clearances to big conventional
clearances you know we had our we call
them jaundice which is Jun D means it
means soldier in in Arabic right and and
so we call them John D's that's what
they called himself Sundays but so we
had John D's like you guys had little
people like you have ended for us we had
in ditch forces they were John D's and
so we would do very conventional
missions with the Jun DS of them and us
you know we'd be overseeing them as they
cleared big sections of the city and
we'd be working in conjunction with the
army so yeah we did a little bit of
everything but see that brings us back
to our side of it where you can give
yourself mental delusion which is our
mission is to go look an area recon so
theoretically you're gonna get inserted
quietly and go about your job and that's
different from you with your point
misses the whole different free online
so theoretically okay we're hoping to
get into our mission to come back and
report or find a fuel line blow it up
or get the peel w get the wiretap give
them intel what your going out and doing
your ie D pickups and and mortars that's
totally different so at least in my mind
I think that's part of my self comfort
factor we're going to get inserted in
couple nice quiet mission for five or
six days take some pictures
that sounds great come on back it's
really cool yeah we're behind enemy
lines
what percentage of operations would you
guys get contacted on oh we left always
left under fire the only question was
how much never had well one they one
where we got you opened up our
discussion tonight there where we got
pulled out there's no fire there because
they came in and got us we had a great
ro N and we were gonna get some POWs but
they pulled us out right away so there's
no gunfire and I'm missing but other
than that every time we left under
gunfire is the only question how much
sucked I looks like the whole jungle is
light enough sometimes only be 2 or 300
and yet you still fooled yourself into
figured hey this recon they're gonna be
different but yeah so I guess my point
was I looked at it and I still look at
it if you are nervous about getting hurt
if you're nervous about something going
wrong to me that's when something goes
wrong yeah when you're nervous about it
now I'm not saying you should be
arrogant about it and think all we're
gonna get away with whatever but I'm
saying
like when you're doing us even when
you're doing like a sport you know even
when you're doing some physical activity
if you if you're afraid you might get
injured to me that's when you get
injured it's when those when you're when
you're afraid I think fear can hurt you
that being said the other side of the
coin is if you have no fear well then
you're definitely you're definitely at
risk he who hesitates is lost there you
go so there's a dichotomy there's a
balanced beat yeah that's where we're so
lucky we you know help us out did a
great job of vetting our indigenous
troops and to go from spider parks to
walk in to Bubba and then back to limb
black and then when I left the team is
in Lynn's hands mm-hm and I came back
Lynn's the one zero
mmm-hmm what more could you ask for that
was just that you know very fortunate
what was your uh your mission planning
like so you guys get at asking how long
does it how long did you guys plan for
if it's just an area mission area tree
constants vary little but the wiretaps
obviously we did ours now as a training
on that and then as time went on you
know first it was just Sal who could do
it and then Sal trained to have and fuck
the guys that were strong to do it all
and as well every every aspect of it and
then we cross trained each other and we
even had so that HAP would it was
beginning to teach a couple to young
guys basic English so if any of us got
killed HAP could take over the radio or
the Indigo so a couple guys are like
Chow and hung as it went Hong came on
the team they picked up Bing was pretty
quick so he worked with him and we
practiced calling in working on the
radio the problems with the batteries
and things like that so we cross trained
everything back and forth and the
wiretap was one particular one were we
had several guys on the team trained up
to do it all everything from known about
the batteries watching it keeping a
battery indicator to getting to put the
wire up the tree or a telephone pole and
when he came down he covered it with mud
that was from that area so it looked
like it was part of that area and try to
cover the wire but as far as the actual
mission planning of okay here's what
we're going in tonight they didn't take
you much because you were running
repetitive type mission right it's a
high degree of similarity the most
important thing was the training so when
you made contact
you could take care of yourself and how
to react try to continue mission but
these were like reconnaissance so once
you've been seen or compromised the
missus compromised would you would be
flying in what was your degree of
certainty on where you were inserted oh
we knew very clear where we're gone so
like in a case we would talk to cubby
we'd send the three L's ease down to
Saigon
and Kobe would go pick a site and then
he would tell me on a radio okay this is
where we're gone and you would be would
you be looking at your map as you
started and he knew what what the frame
was it would be in within that map that
we or that section of map that we akan
remember when we first you know as a
radio man believe it or not when GPS is
first came out the radio man kind of got
saddled with the GPS because it was a
piece of electronic equipment but and
then no one else could work with
electronic or women so so I would be
usually a lot of times be carrying the
GPS as opposed to the appointment and
the point man you know which it was
still using map and compasses in the
early 90s but the GPS wouldn't always
work well in a helicopter and so
sometimes it took me you know this is
some training operations where I learned
oh so I'm not what I think I am and you
get out and that GPS finally finds
itself and you realize you're three
klicks away from where you're supposed
to be or whatever and it's bad and
that's why we'd go yeah I went back to
hey when I'm in the helicopter I'm on a
map so that way when my boss looks at me
and says hey where're we supposed to be
either yes or no like don't get out of
the bird or okay we're good but but that
so I was thinking about that for you
guys you'd be doing the same thing as
you approach to okay yep there's that
terrain feature there's this other
terrain feature cooler where we're
supposed to be yep and then less also
want to know where the water was because
some of the targets they had more more
streams of things so we would carry less
water IVA Lou just carry one canteen
with the purification pills so that we
were in for several days like would that
go for by the end of the first day we
had gone through some water and we all
took a turn going into the little stream
put the purification pills in hit the
water and let it sit for a couple hours
before you drank it did you get
acclimated where you needed less water
oh yeah absolutely
less water and I can truly say I never
defecated in layoffs somehow the body
just tightened up then they had no shit
pills that guys would take so they Lily
would not go to the bathroom I worried
about those you know I would meet there
oh yeah I was like
anyway for numerous reasons that the
creative mind could think about but so I
didn't but my body never had and we
never did it
the in the do you guys didn't is STM I
did you guys have you guys did you guys
use imagery at all like an overhead
imagery nothing no some of the gun the
Cobras or no some of the first calf
helicopters had some trying to what I
are they would have the ability to see
through the clouds in style okay
and it was just a very primitive both
the beginning whereas the Cobra
conscious didn't have it but the first
calf could get low into the jungle and
navigate and fog and stuff to get down
to our guys but no you guys wouldn't see
photographs of the areas where you were
going into it all know the only time was
down in Cambodia for that mission err
where that was
now that base was really close to Saigon
close to Mac V headquarters and we may
have had overviews I just forget for up
north that one down there it's Texas
stuck in my mind and then what was your
what was your op temple like in other
words how often were you going in the
field well through November December we
if we weren't on the if we weren't on
the ground we were getting ready to go
back to the next day that's why it was
such a push push push and I've rotated
our little people out because they were
just getting beat and we had trained him
up so by November December all the cross
training we had done all those months
you know South could take a day off even
hep could take a day off we had a couple
two guys that could speak enough English
if anything happened to me or Bubba they
could take care of the radio due to
comms and so we rotated him through but
it was every day and then if the weather
came we get a break and sort of know and
the rule of thumb was if you ran a
mission for five days you came back you
got five days off so you could clean up
get back in shape get the team ready but
for that period of time we had minimal
teams that the teams at fo b 1 had
become so between disease health God's
getting wiped out teams getting blown
away we were one of the few teams in
camp that was fully operational so
that's why I was the other pressure we
had like I remember they asked me just
say hey you're the only got to be god
you're going to say afternoon here's
your target go eat okay so we didn't and
then we got shot out they come back the
next day and so there was no this the OP
temple was supposed to be robbed my
mission five to ten days if you're lucky
will it ever happened some guys did
don't get me wrong we had some guys that
were able to stay on the ground amazing
but in our case we didn't so it would be
very flexible then you really take less
than less than six guys a few guys ran
with four and at the end of my tour duty
second tour I tried a four-man team but
we had this whole issue with the radio
stuff just so he could move faster she
wanted to try anything something
different because when we had moved fast
we had success in getting away from the
LZ and that caused them confusion so if
we broke what our SOPs were it worked
but the eight-man was too much too much
I felt more comfortable with six it was
a lot of firepower we had diem sitting a
nine there and then all the Americas at
the EM City nines - and then how often
would you get legitimate R&R you had one
a year at one for a tour duty you get
five days anywhere you wanted so I went
to Hong Kong bought my stereo buy time
spoke of money said I bought a nice
stereo state-of-the-art sent home to mom
and dad they they my little brother put
it together he was good at that stuff
yeah and that's it other than that
there's no no one on our if we got an F
plw ah then you would have gotten more
yeah we would have what was the offer
for catching a bad guy an R&R anywhere
in the world and you got a 100
bonus how many days five like a regular
R&R hey oh yeah it was yeah that's why
we lost it for him yeah I cried when
spider said no a hundred bucks how much
was a hundred bucks how about how much
was your normal paycheck how much you
make a month back then oh I don't know
well when we went through jump school
now I'm only a private e one right I got
a hard percent pay raise my jump pay
that's getting paid $50 a month the jump
pay was 55 so 55 was a constant then
later maybe e 2 is like 75 I never paid
it was never enough so 100 bucks was
like a hundred bucks was like a a month
to pay basically he has a lot of money
even n a c-note was a big deal
absolutely and then when you guys would
come back you were talking about this
how you would sit there in debrief would
you debrief your your team would you
guys sit down in debrief what happened
what went wrong what we're right we
always talked to little people maybe not
right away because s 2 would want to
know what happened so we would go in for
an immediate debrief go back to team
make sure they had food for tonight and
stuff and then go back for a final
after-action report which would go
through talking about everything from
the vegetation the type of Hills animals
you encountered all that kind of just
crazy stuff the fauna oh my god the
questions there it was just after was
like always the same there's layoffs
yeah Triple Canopy has pretty dangerous
the NVA are pretty dedicated and then
anything specifics off the target from
that that they could learn from how long
how long did it take you to become the
one zero well in my case I got in
country in May the spider put me on a
team at the end of May we trained June
and July had a couple in country like
literally ambushes locally and then we
had a the practice mission in August and
then we did it first wiretap another
wiretap but the air force sensors we did
two of those missions in September we
had two monsoons too
it's a lot of between the rain we had
like weeks we would just rain see like
it rained every day
you ever see you horizontal rain
yeah I've seen as much which so you guys
would not run missions during him on
Susie's no you used too much too much
whether it was gonna be too bad your saw
your socked and you couldn't get out of
the base the King bees couldn't get to
the base so how long so how long was
that like four months before you were
yeah four months and and we might and
how many missions did you run before you
were one a one zero
I had five missions under my belt we had
a to practice the to wiretap and then
Don Walken echo for mmm and by that time
when they came to me he said you know
welcome got promoted to a cubby rider
and because Pat Walker's was leaving
there's an opening so he went there and
they gave me the option are you ready
well we see what happen with Alabama
with Lyn black in October when they put
a guy on a team that didn't had no
experience so I talked it over with it
happened salad I said look this
situation I don't know who they're going
to give us so what about I'll be the
ones hero and spider had thought that
was okay to do it talk to walkins
and they all said well you're ready if
you want to try it and we need to know
who could they had new people coming
into camp and some these guys were the
older ones who had no experience on
layoffs but didn't want anything to do
with them and it has so many younger
guys who are coming in like like Jim
Robson who was on the team for one
mission and we didn't know how they
would stand up so our guys were happy
and then Bubba came in bubbling the guy
named the frenchman doug Letourneau the
frenchman came in together and the
freshman got picked for Virginia and I
got Bubba they were buddies they caught
be training group together
yeah that's I have you so you'd been in
the Army for like a couple years and you
never in charge of a recon team yeah got
in the army December 66 became a-10 in
October or 68 so you figure you're
almost two years yeah
because the whole SF training between
that and going through basic jump school
and then we had that training before
Vietnam the RTT training which was
different but that's just because we're
combo geeks oh the RTT training was just
radio ready to teletype got it they
wanted top secret clearance men on those
machines how much did you see the
tactics that you guys were using change
over time I think by the time like when
you read we few by Nick Brock housing
some of those guys were all carrying
either RPGs or an m60 so they were just
going in heavier and they would go into
bigger team and they were just
anticipating the contact more or as we
thought we would try to go in and try to
escape and evade and to the point where
you hope you can get at least some of
the mission done or to get some Intel
reports about troop movements truck
stuff like that or get a good wiretap so
the biggest thing that changed was the
guys started going in heavier and
actually bringing automatic weapons oh
yeah or belt-fed machine guns sure that
makes sense I every single time I read
any of your operations I want nothing
more than a belfie machine so the weaves
we didn't know who was gonna carry did
you know the seals had the stoner oh
yeah did you guys ever think about using
that we thought about it a lot but and
it was a great system we heard many
great reports about it but again the
stoner system you need all the ammo you
had to get the supply systems set up and
we just weren't sure if we were gonna be
able to get the guarantee if we convert
it who would it be just the Americans we
want everybody with common weapons so
that somebody gets blown up their weapon
gets blown they know how to use the
other guy's weapon you're on it and you
have the same magazines everything all
that sure and what about the mission set
itself did you guys did you notice that
change over time while you were there
later we began to get more point targets
like in on the ground one of my favorite
stories was the Frenchman he goes in to
a Cecile type mission the CIA comes and
says we know about the NVA they're
floating 55-gallon drums down the river
into a storage area deep in lay us so we
want you guys to go in but we don't
trust you with the device they had a
device that they screwed into a
55-gallon drum so what we're going to do
is and that would be like a tracking
device
no no explosive in nature oh that's
right that's right yeah that's okay so
here's what they said we're gonna meet
you on this hilltop in lay us
so Doug was the one one on RT Virginia
Gunther Wald was the one zero they go in
hump with three days get to the
mountaintop
there's the CIA with a couple guys okay
here's your device go install it now
comforting wall was a marine so you
think that he'd be the guy doing a
swimming right he goes I'm an e6
Frenchman you're an e4 hit the workers
so the CIA gave the disclosure device
humped down the mountain get to the
river and then now they're on a river
with all the stuff going by the drums
and some have NVA troops riding the
drums or being present with a boat or
something
so in between artists Doug strips down
goes in gets a drum brings it back puts
in the explosive device swims it back
out and comes back soaking wet and not
happy he's for Southern California he's
he's really not happy but two days later
they're getting extracted now the King
bees come extract and they're getting
extracted his use explosion and had
sonic boom that literally moved the
aircraft and the guys were on the string
swinging from the sonic boom looked back
there goes the fuel dump
beautiful mission yeah so those are kind
so the point mission the the wiretap
stick in the pipelines we have more
reports of pipelines and then also they
were doing some trail work
trying to figure out how to look like
you'd be a stream but they have things
that's one of our miss about the orchid
mission to get in there see well how'd
it go on its water and who you go in and
while you're there blow it up maybe with
the truck on it sure let's talk a little
bit about gear and you put you actually
have a section in song chronicles and
it's an across the fence to where you
talk about stuff you carry and stuff
that you didn't carry and some of the
stuff that you didn't carry no underwear
never no socks never and that's because
you're just want to stay dry as much as
possible yeah and both those things just
hold water and keep moisture in yeah and
then black when he came oh I had a mate
that was stealing all my underwear I
went over with eight or ten pair of the
jockey shorts right okay so I was down
on my last pair and the maid was
literally stealing could think selling
on the black market they're relatively
clean relatively new mom bought me a
whole bunch of stuff with socks and
everything so yeah we had army socks but
so anyways I talked to Lynn oh I can't
believe my maze been stealing my
underwear I we pulled down his little I
doubt there's my underwear so I said
here take the last one have a good day
lingo don't wear that stuff because you
get jungle rock crotch rot and he says
the same thing put away your socks well
you know at first couple weeks the
jungle boots were really tougher on my
feet but he was right yeah once you get
a bunch get your feet broken in and the
jungle boots broken in and that's how
you go through the water we we did
somewhere in country stuff where you
were in the rice paddies oh my god but
they would dry out quicker you have to
worry about the socks so no helmet never
no body armor nope and your body armor
talked about this attack that was big
clumsy heavy it didn't work
no entrenching tool never no bayonet no
sleeping bag no hammock no poncho no
poncho line or no ground path
correct you are not travelling for
comfort never we had to carry it as you
know know that feeling yeah what you're
taking to the field you're carrying you
don't have your maid with you yeah that
that rucksack gets heavy too
so quick yeah and arms are like small we
had the indigenous rucksacks uh-huh and
what and so you want you put the radio
and put the sweater underneath no radio
so it protect your back and they throw
some rations master a couple archer and
magazines in there and then extra hand
grenades and study nine rounds and a
battery for good luck man yeah you guys
no dog tags no military ID your idea of
any kind no rank no name tags no jump
wings no CIB no patches no unit
identifiers nothing no pictures of momma
no pictures of momma right totally slick
so those are the things you didn't carry
things you did carry car 15 oh love it
you love the car fifty oh yeah so imma
back to my second tour Rock Meyers was
an s4 he's healing he'd been wounded I
came back he says your back said I got a
present for me gave me a brand new car
15 it was still in the box
take it out stone it all the tin foil
and all the oils and greases and stuff
and you take it out took it down to
rains it was perfectly zero never
touched that went crazy just put a
little cloth strap on it and went to
work and and you never had problems with
that weapon never yeah they did yours
have a forward assist on it
did you yep just lord assist yeah so
that was a that was a car 15 Wow so the
m16 would it with a classical stock yeah
and a shortened barrel yeah it's weird
so many people and myself being one of
them complaining about the car the car
15 or the m4 frame and now the m4 is not
a lot nicer
I mean them for law have you - you got
the rails and everything oh yeah we win
the light load thing those I hate look
like you got anything but a cigarette
lighter on here sometimes I would be
surprised
- so that's awesome you used a cravat
for your sling yes
well yeah I did that during my second
tour could they had the cravats quiet
and then god forbid if he ever needed a
cravat and because I was carried I
always wore one around my neck had one
on my head and then one on the car
fifteen of course you carried bandages
yeah we had crevasse in cases as at the
very bottom of the rucksack we would get
is sort of one of those things they'd
never wear a sling and some guys would
say that get caught up and that's just
man especially when you're in a
leadership position you need a sling cuz
you got a look at your map you got a
pull out you know yeah you got to do
stuff you know and the other thing is
you don't have a sling and you get blown
up
yeah dig where's your weapon you have no
idea when you wake up so yeah but then
there's some you know some people just
they wouldn't carry sling mark leaves
one of my shank on receive just no sling
no that was like real a man thing to do
was no sling you on the m60 or these
days at mark 48 really yeah yeah how
small this guy strong yes strong m79 you
carried sawed-off oh yes I cannot
believe that me and my guys did not
think of sawing off our I'm 70 that's
cuz I guarantee guys were to saw it off
the excess oh yeah my first
self-inflicted wound was from a
sawed-off m79 what you do well we're in
a process of cutting him down the
question was how far he cut the barrel
down so we finally cut it right down to
the last hinge mmm were it's the last
one that's yeah this to the bottom of
the frame got it so you crack put the
round in so we we kept bringing it back
so we're down to range we're there and
the question was because you cut the
barrel off you need the number of
rotations
now our weapons guys knew that but I was
me and Rick how it work on well guys and
I didn't really ask it's just the
question was fire I see so on this day I
fire it fairly close it goes being
popped in that noise and 39 makes and
then it went all they popped being like
that and I go
so I go to Rick Carris it I think Abby
just hit me pull my strategy dumbass you
just shot yourself
my first self-inflicted wound but the
good news was that I'm sitting I worked
and of course we cut the handle down
yeah to just have enough tea you could
hold on to because that way is less less
weapon firepower
oh yeah cut that weapon down by half oh
yeah I was looking at the pictures you
have it in your book it's that thing is
tiny tiny but effective Charlie hated
those things and at one point you had a
you had a holster for that thing yeah
that's the John Wayne yes that's still
in layoffs with my SOG knife Hey I had
it somebody had crafted it and I put it
on so yeah that that was perfect but
never had a Nova from that point I just
like everybody else they just carried it
one doesn't were d-ring we taped it so
be quiet though you carried 34 20 round
max each Pat each with 18 rounds each so
that's six hundred and twelve rounds for
good luck yeah that's not all we carried
extra like a pouch with a couple extra
clips and in case we need to reload the
thirty-four magazines and you went on
you mentioned you had few missions where
you were down to your last one or two at
least twice I remember echo 4 is the
first time did you always hang on to
your magazines when you were out at
dependent on the degree of intensity of
the firefight if I had time we keep best
for a happy I'll bring back my damn
magazines did you stuff on your shirt
yeah because the web gear would be tight
so our jungle fatigues were out yeah so
you had the pants but then the harness
from the the web gear was held
everything in when I came in with stuff
magazine or shirt and then but with body
armor you can't do that so now I'm a
scary like pouches or just dropping
their leg cargo pockets or whatever yeah
our preferred thing with the BA are
bells because you could put four
magazines in and one across the top it
was a nice pass the BA our belts at the
half
- perfect for the 20-round magazines
that's a lot of just you know we would
normally carry seven to ten thirty round
max so we carried like I mean sometimes
I guess meant more than that but not
know 600 rounds but you weren't
anticipated being alone for a while
no we weren't fighting divisions worth
of people either so yeah you know and I
guess we did what we did have is we
always had heavy machine guns you know
who so that makes a big difference to I
guess you know you we would have mark 48
which is seven six two and then the mark
46 which is five five six you know
that's basically like a little stoner
and and 60 the modern versions of those
two things but yeah you know so we had
it's all - right yeah well that's the
the mark 46 is a saw okay yeah yeah so
we had those and those guys would carry
a lot of routes a lot of rounds like 800
to a thousand sometimes more on carried
carried like that over a thousand yeah
and I had guys go Winchester go run out
of bullets
really yeah with that many so yeah I
guess maybe that was the differentiator
you carried ten to twelve frag grenades
that's a lot of frag grenades I guess
when you're going picking fights with
divisions you got to carry a lot of frag
grenades oh yeah and they always kept
the last one that was the one up here
I'm just I'm not gonna be a peel W
absolutely we would carry I don't know
well I would carry like one or two how
often would you how often would you
anymore to to them hopefully never yeah
you know and especially I'm in a
leadership position I'm hopefully not
fuckin grenades but uh ya know then you
know the big difference especially in
Ramadi I mean in Ramadi I remember
explaining to the guys that relieved us
you know we had a big overhead imagery
yeah and I put my hand on the map and I
said no matter where you put your hand
on this map you'll be touching
the unit so like annual this is you know
probably within three to five hundred
meters of you anywhere you were in
Raimondi there's a friendly unit really
so that's why you know you were gonna
get reinforcements you were gonna get
tanks you're gonna get Bradley fighting
vehicles so yeah yeah but in between
that time you earned your pay you have
to earn your pay yeah yeah I was talking
to late look what leaf that's another
thing so Lafe Leif's got a chapter in
dichotomy a leadership where he's
talking about preparing / / / preparing
for too many contingencies and he talks
about it was his first patrol out on out
going out with a Marine Corps into
daytime patrol and he's talking about
how much stuff he cared he carried all
this stuff but one of the thing he
carried is you know eight grenades or
something like that and you know he
reflects on how that was we just way too
many and I was like hey man you know
Tilted go out in the field with less
than ten so different ao dai would
adjusted her grenades I wonder how much
you would have changed if you had to
wear body armor or if you would have
decided not to or whatever you know it's
interesting that's an interesting
develop I'll tell you if we even had
today's state-of-the-art
a never would've worn it it's just too
much weight and you have to be able to
move I mean you know not to mention
you're so damn lucky no bullets are
gonna hit you yeah that's why I crawled
a lot dressed with a low profile but no
I I probably would declined it because
of the weight there as it was in our AO
maybe another AO with different
situations more flexibility with assets
and the only thing that's interesting is
you know one of the reasons why you wear
a helmet now isn't just to protect your
head it's cuz that's where your nods
mount on to your night vision oh yeah
night vision mount on here so you they
do have a contraption that's like a
headband looking thing I don't think
they make it anymore but but where you
could wear that but you know your knobs
mount on your your night-vision mounts
on your helmet your that's just the way
it is I see no ciliates we've got 15
dogs
that's a cool I want one sit yeah yeah
that's go time windows flip down
all right but instead of wearing a
helmet you wore a cravat the green for
that green curve out on your head one
around your neck you had you weren't
regular army fatigues yeah there is
sterile fatigues that had a two pockets
up top with an angle mm-hmm and two
pockets down here to hung out and then
we customized and we had the the tailor
put in pockets here and so for mirrors
Maps morphine syrettes it's all closed
right here and then we had a pockets on
each arm to put other things up there
were pin players other think that's such
that we did too so we did even before
even the 90s before the everyone because
now the fatigues come issued with
pockets on the arms I think but we used
to take them off and sew them on and
that's where you'd keep your your pens
and your notebooks and your pen flares
and your and your signal mirror yeah and
then on the ones on your chest you had
maps and more if you need an extra
notebook your URC 10 emergency radio and
then you had a you wore a watch a Seiko
yeah a luminous watch you wore gloves
always just cut out the thumb index
finger and then the middle finger just
cut it to tip so you grab the tape on
the magazine sort of firefight same
thing same thing we would do but you
always wear gloves the good otherwise
your hands are just getting destroyed
the jungle forget about it yeah because
lot of times we wind up get have to get
a new pair of gloves we just get torn up
so much and the jungle fatigues man
those wait a minute wait a minute of
inés and the thorns because you know
there are wait a minute you get caught
into it the you walk in to your leg goes
into the pins that's come together so
you had to stop and then get the pin to
get your leg otherwise it goes deeper
into your into your like well no did you
carry any kind of mosquito net for your
head no how come
never thought about a mosquito net for
the head yeah
well I used to this is like the most
brilliant thing I think it was an
Australian guys told me this you I would
have liked a little square of mosquito
netting hmm and when we would stop
patrolling I would take out that little
square put it over my head right over my
right over my floppy hat and talk it in
and all of a sudden you not getting
chewed apart by mosquitoes oh yeah one
night with them one time we did a
practice mission east of the I saw in
the morning I couldn't I couldn't open
my eyes had been bitten so much by
mosquitoes my face was puffed out you
need that mosquito net needed Oh had I
only known I should have thought about
stuff about that one I had a guy we were
doing some training and none of us had
mosquito netting except for the officer
and so the officer was sleeping heartily
like just fully and one of the other
young listed guys was catching
mosquitoes and putting him inside this
guy's Wow not only those mosquitoes were
trapped in there with him they were
wrapped in there and they couldn't get
out they were just having a feast
trapped hungry mosquitoes that thought
yeah so but no not for you no mosquito
net no I hadn't thought about that one
leeches oh you guys ran into a lot of
leeches always yeah we had the bug
repellent for that it even ray the bug
the repellant on him once you got sucked
on by a leech yeah they would instantly
fall but he always tried to wait try to
see if he could jiggle them off because
you knew the bug repellent could be
smelled mm-hmm but a bad guys so then
you had your on your web gear which was
the old world war two web gear you had
on your left harness you had your k bar
handle down or a sod knife or SOG knife
until you lost it to us that's what we
need to do a recovery mission for get
the song back yes
I'll handle down sure that's how you
rolled it cuz this way you pull it on
you're ready what's up here used to pour
out in the jungle you might get caught
up in the vines got it got it
you got hand grenades there because you
were basically covered in hand grenades
oh yeah
smoke you had there you had some some
you know bandages there on your right
harness you had your strobe light you
had more hand grenades
you had your d-ring and you had more
smoke grenades then on your belt you had
one canteen usually it depends on on
target sometimes it'd be maybe two but
usually one and then one I had a second
one in my in my backpack rucksack you
normally wouldn't get would you get
thirsty was there normally enough water
uh in the jungle wasn't as bad as
Cambodia so but yeah you get thirsty
you're hopping up and down there's a
couple times be particularly that day we
went straight up with the orchids that
was a day we got we were all out of
water not fun no so you had one canteen
you had a Willie Pete grenade we had
your survival axe which was the Frank
and Warren survival axe type - indeed
that's what I won wasn't my did I want
to type - I looked him up and had like a
hook at the top yeah you went through
and when he came back on the on the back
pool you could try to make it effective
to cut if particular cutting vines and
that thing came with you all the time
every mission I got it home under my
desk right now a case and the tutor
comes in I'm ready I like it intruders
feeling lucky yeah luck meet mister tilt
I compass around your neck
you used to curve at for your belt yes
so the belt I was talking about before
is the belt of your web gear but just
the health of your pants was just uh was
a cravat you carried a Swiss Army knife
you carried a gas mask always you always
carried a gas man have we had teams that
got hit and in camps that have been hit
by the enemy used - yes
and they use I forget what the the
instance were but there were a couple
times that the enemy had used gas on our
people unless as well as with a CIA
operation but we weren't told that but
we had cold evidence that they had done
it and that they could hit one of our
Recon teams so we had to carry that
bulky a sting at all times I was gonna
say but and this is this was the the
concern was tear gas well tear gas or
who else knows what they had I mean
these are communists not going to play
by the rules of engagement you know not
in Laos because yeah that's a thousand I
was think with all this crap that you're
carrying and a gas masks are just huge
and bulky yeah left hip out carry that
all the time
had to and we used them twice and we in
fact we had designed a mission one of
our missions was to when we gotta strike
two from a target an EM a target we saw
a road that had little guard station a
Guard Station but it was north of the
DMZ River so the quest for getting a
live PLW we found out that we had one of
our guys that did a VR and it flew a
couple of rows they saw these little
weigh stations along the way so our
thought was we'll get gas gas and they
said they had a knockout gas at the time
right so we practiced for a couple days
with tear gas and I had to get the
helicopter pilots and the gun crews
everybody would their mass and then have
mass that they could talk to each other
and then talk to us and so we practiced
for several days training with the
helicopters coming in the I and the
mission plan was go up in the middle of
the day go to one of those camps hit it
gas it go in and scar from up and go
home get a five-day pass a hundred bucks
yeah but they and they had a special
knockout gas that we're supposed to use
at the end they they wouldn't let us
they wouldn't give us the gas or I don't
know if they had it they wouldn't give
us the knockout gas so then another
mission came up that we had a bright
light to run and we never got
to the concept of doing it and you
carried a you usually carried one
grenade for your forty mike-mike that
was to your gasps always sure case we
needed it and that was what would your
what would your tactic be on using that
but usually it would be to you know to
create disorder because you hit somebody
with tear gas if is far away it that
that would distract him for a second
take their mind off a business or at
least make them have a harder time to
kill us and we also carried a grass a
gas grenade local okay so we had in our
SOP procedure that the word I forgot to
heckle was but we had a signal or a sign
for CS gas so if we're getting so over R
underwear at the Papas CS to break the
break to charge with some of our teams
did they used it in the operation
Tailwind quite effectively saved their
bacon so the idea would be hey this is
gonna linger whereas a frag grenade it
goes off you either wound guys or you
don't you either kill guys or you don't
but that's it it's over yeah whereas gas
you you can really disrupt them because
now you've got guys coughing and yeah
puking or whatever and it's and it hangs
to the ground and then it hangs around
as long as the wind it's got a little
hang around got it left pant pocket you
had a marking panel large and small
right pant pocket pen flares dehydrated
lerp ration bug repellant for leeches an
extra cot and extra bandage did anybody
carry IV a summer Oh guys did okay uh
limp black did and we had I think South
Carolina one of our in ditch Gary one we
had an IB and the same line solution
that came in a canister it's always had
one in case we need it in your rucksack
yet sir you got your PRC 25 which you
guys called the prick 25 yeah I think I
was I think I was outlawed from calling
it a prick because that that PRC 25 so
the PRC 25 was replaced by the PR 77 the
press 77
and I will say it was 1969 or something
like that when I got the seal team one
that's what I used was a Pete was one of
the radios that we had that story was a
PRC 77 yeah which came directly from the
PRC 25 so you'd carry that you had the
big whip antenna but you wouldn't you'd
have the little tape antenna on there so
you know right identified as the radio
guy because otherwise you're gonna know
yeah over in our case the antenna we
just get it and bend it down
come beneath your arm just stick it into
the fatigues and so be low profile on it
then you had your your 1c rat of fruit
that was like your that was as your your
go-to indeed you'd carry one of those
two of those something like that
he's just one could after a while you
know we kept getting shot out so often
Slyke okay I'm not too much weight yeah
yeah yeah after you had your extra mags
in there he's got an extra m79 Browns
you had your army long sleeve sweater
you had a plastic rain jacket toilet
paper even though you apparently never
used it correct but you can also use it
to pack wounds there you go
extra battery for the for the prick 25
and the URC 10 extra smoke grenades
extra canteen water extra ration and
then you had your claim or or claymores
with five and ten second fuses and on
top of that the 22 caliber hushpuppy on
some operations sometimes yeah and all
this when you weighed yourself you'd be
about 90 pounds heavy right around there
yeah it was it was an old rickety s
scale so I just jumped on carrying
everything just to see what it was well
that's a heavy load out I'll tell you
right now that's a heavy load out that
is absolutely all of 90 pounds when you
start talking about 600 rounds of
ammunition research talking about 10 10
to 12 hand grenades
smoke smoke grenades are heavy as hell
we got all that material in them that
smokes sure they're big giant beasts and
a Willie Peter was the really matters
heavy to crazy mouth
and I guess like I said and like you
said you're carrying all that firepower
because the operations your to carrying
a crazy amount of firepower cause you're
doing crazy operations yeah and again
from talking to the other one zeros Pat
walkins and McGovern because initially I
don't know what the loads were but they
kept increasing him because there were
several times and they ran out of ammo
already got close to running out that's
the last thing in the world you want you
know yeah awesome well you know that's a
little over two hours right now and it's
been a quick night yeah indeed indeed
but Gunny you got any closing thoughts
no just to thank you for having me in
three times and we've gained some extra
tests like I said before we were just
chatting is these stories always felt
more significant in terms of the stories
about what SOG did and the men more
importantly men and also like I said to
you earlier my stuff is hairy but if you
had a hairy scale on one to ten I mean I
feel I put myself at a five or six
compared to the guys that got the Medal
of Honor the guys that didn't come home
that went down fighting getting overrun
by the NVA and we we could just talk
about Medal of Honor missions of guys
standing there just fighting off and
dying on the LZ putting their people on
a helicopter first John Kayden Berg
Johnny gallon time and again our SF God
would take care of the little people you
even get him on the chopper get him out
and so those stories I felt with great
valor and so I thank you for the low
exposure to your audience well we
appreciate them we'll we'll bring you
back on and we'll get and I know you and
I are talking about other guys that
we're going to come on and all those
stories of those heroes we'll we'll get
them out there because people want to
know I want to hear them I want to know
as much as I can about them and
and and you know we'll get you back well
I'm ready to roll
so thank you and I thank you for the
time and also your honor you're like mr.
social media now I don't realize that
you have to give me a full briefing word
does so you're on Twitter who neckla
Cara let's get me squared away you're on
Twitter we haven't quite figured out
Twitter yet apparently your that makes
two of us
you're old your old Twitter handle was
at SOG Chronicles your new Twitter
handle is at John striker Meyer that's
that's where it's at right now yes sir
that's right
all right so people will start trying to
communicate with you on that
good luck I'm gonna call it a presence
aid president Trump could you help me
out of my Twitter of President Trump it
Suites all the time the king at Twitter
yeah yes he is hey it was I'm sorry you
know you'll be able to you'll be able to
you win you that's the incredible thing
about Twitter is everybody has a
platform it's incredibly good sometimes
it's impressed incredibly bad but
everybody has a platform so no the cool
thing about it is people have been you
know talking to me and hitting me up and
just thanking you for your service
thanking you for coming on thank you for
sharing the story so it'll be cool that
they'll be able to actually thank you
instead of just telling me to tell you
things I just go to our website they got
the link in there for email for the
old-fashioned route saw Chronicles
dot-com saw Chronicles calm horn that B
we're thankful on there I wanted to
close out reading one last thing and
this is your dedication for the book sod
Chronicles one and it said it says this
book is dedicated to the SOG men and
their courageous indigenous team members
who went across the fence into Laos
Cambodia in North Vietnam during the
eight-year secret war and to the and to
the brave aviators and crew members of
the Army Air Force Marine Corps and our
fearless allies from the 219 South
Vietnamese Air Forces Special Operations
Squadron
the legendary King bees who supported
who supported SOG teams on the ground
this book is also for every man in SOG
and the aviators who made the ultimate
sacrifice far outside the boundaries of
conventional the
nom war that America saw reported on the
nightly news give their closing note
today
1598 Americans that are m.i.a and
Southeast Asia from the Vietnam War
fifty Green Berets alone in layoffs
still am ia including a hundred and
forty plus a vias that died strictly
supporting our mission and this week the
National League appeal wmia Founders Day
having his 50th annual meeting in
Arlington on this topic
they've been diligent and an Mills
Griffiths is the CEO she's putting it
all together they worked with the
Pentagon she had been on this mission
from day one and our prayers are with
them to continue because they're pushing
to bring our people home absolutely and
if you want to put that out either on
SOG chronicles put a link to how people
can support that cause people will
absolutely support that cause oh okay
we'll do a dessert yes absolutely we can
make that happen
huh thank you airborne all right well
like I said you have an opening invite
on here
anytime you want you let us know we're
here and we'll get some of your friends
on and thanks for coming on yourself
thanks for sharing your stories and most
of all more than anything else thanks
for your service and sacrifice
likewise brother you've been there you
seen the elephant appreciate it
and once again John a striker Meyer has
left the building
tilt tilt has left the building mm-hmm
finishing up the three podcasts wage on
strike a minor yeah sappers sappers
asked him what sappers was who work as
there's various references first second
and this past one to sappers and more
notably one if you remember the movie
predator the first one he says sappers
those sapper has been on a sense blah
blah blah whatever they're interesting
and I always wondered what's a sapper
special group Vietnam
North Vietnamese group of anti-american
fighters trained specifically right
right I got that right did I remember
that correctly yeah that's that's the
definition that John striker Meyer just
gave you yeah cool
what else Jaco well I would say no
awesome awesome to have John Stryker
Meyer on here and just to hear him talk
about what human beings can do right
what people human beings can do and it's
interesting because you ever look at
dogs and you think oh there's a little
tiny Chihuahua and then there's like a
German Shepherd yeah and you think those
are the same animal Yeah right yes they
are technically technically human beings
think like you look at him John Stryker
Meyer hmm
he's like a German Shepherd yeah and
then you got people running around
they're Chihuahuas defense the
chihuahuas but you Chihuahuas not gonna
yes
fend off hordes no no - I was not
calling in airstrikes danger-close no so
I guess my point is that human beings
that do have capabilities and I think
that when you listen to tilt you realize
that I can probably do better I know
that's what I realize I think I can do
better than I'm doing right now
yeah I think I can I can push the
envelope a little bit yeah move further
toward the potential the part that kind
of will probably will stick with me is
how he didn't carry poncho like the
sleeves no come no I want it if we have
to go sleep I'm just gonna sleep right
here in the hand on the anthill just
whatever
see that part when I was a kid
the kid that was viable but now you need
comfort yeah I'm weak yeah
so that part maybe I have to mentally
maybe work on that you know all right
let's face it there are ways to get
better yes sir there is maybe sleeping
without a ground pad is one of them
yeah maybe another one is trained in
jiu-jitsu oh yeah big time
that's a I mean so I was training the
other day with Noah Oliver right and
knows been training and he's kind of
sorting out you know how you go in
phases of training partners and you know
I've been training with Andy for like
the last like three months you know more
than so man but he's been like beat me
down the other day yesterday yesterday
before whatever and yeah he beat me down
but at the same time I didn't leave
thinking like oh my gosh Georgia do
socks you know when you get beat down
you think of okay what do I need to do
to that's it correct at it yes
well especially well when you have
training partners that you like and you
trust and you you know you you enjoy
what you get from the training whatever
regardless you got beat down or not I
think your mind on it will start
automatically go to that I think most of
the time it's usually when I don't know
the other circumstances then you'll be
all salty make excuses or something like
that either way so I'm thinking you know
of all the things and then I arrive at
the concept of men the in any other
situation you take that kind of like
just physical turmoil mm-hmm
not only do you get beat but it was like
kind of hard you know usually I don't
feel this good about it I'm not looking
forward to the next time you know like
come on let's face it you do a hardened
metcon you're like boom I'm glad that's
over with but in this case you are
looking for it Tom next one yeah you're
looking forward to the next why you
looking forward to just training more in
general there's a short-term and
long-term payoff for this jujitsu thing
interesting oh yeah very true not to
mention the capability that you wind up
with so we're pro Jiu Jitsu is what
we're did it we're a hundred thousand
percent short-term and long-term there's
no there's no dichotomy
there's just short-term gain long-term
gain
yes in my opinion but it could be argued
that Oh its word what about the day in
what about sometimes when people don't
want to Train they let the jujitsu
window closed
like reconfirmed is a thing it is the
thing but that's you know what I kind of
arrived at as well the days that you
actually don't want to Train are way
more rainer than you might think like
have you ever said man i really don't
feel like training and then you make the
drive to the gym you get to the gym you
training partner show up you right when
you go to shake hands and you still feel
like I really don't want to train around
Argos you have never have never right
hardly ever I can't think of one single
time I've thought I came to him one time
and I got there and I was like I still
don't want to train but it was because
there was only like three people there
and they were like really brand new at
the time and then I was like and I just
went home one time in my whole life but
I did I literally did not feel like a
anyway legitimate usually if you don't
feel like training it's not that you
don't feel like that's never happened to
me it's you don't feel like training
it's you don't feel like getting off the
couch getting into your car getting your
gear getting you know doing that that's
what you don't feel like doing oh you
feel like training because when it's
time to Train it's good fun every single
time that's what I think it's a weird
aspect that jiu-jitsu is fun it's fun
yeah I have a feeling sometimes when I
change it to where I'm literally like
kind of beside myself with how fun that
just oh yeah yeah you know and that's
sometimes I'm getting beat down and I'm
thinking that sometimes I'm winning and
I'm thinking but either way I'm like
yeah it's it's kind of like a feeling
that's very hard to to describe even
yeah I would I would agree with that
yeah because you have that obviously the
physical part of it right yes yes that's
always good you know that but this is
like it's like prospect if you roll with
like guys who are like good then they're
not good because they're so athletic
even though they might be athletic
they're good because they know what to
do like a Dean Lister like Greg McIntyre
these guys who like
if it chain if you don't think your way
into or out of you the situation you
want man you're you're just not gonna do
it you know so it's that problem-solving
task that's just intertwine and the
whole thing I think that's what makes it
fun
that's what I think agree anyway G
Mogi streets whatever if you want to do
gear you're gonna need a key you get
Agee from origin or didn't mean that
unless we can get me very selections on
there the best me in America by the way
made in America yeah and just kind of
massive shipment of cotton and I'm up
I'm talking not talking to woven I'm
talking unwoven those strands of cotton
check out check out check out the
Instagram there's pallets and pallets
that are there and it's just you think
okay this cotton is gonna get woven and
then turned into goose that I'm gonna
wear what does the cotton look like when
it comes from pallets because it's got
little spools of it's not even it's not
just cotton by the way it's it's a
blended material so slobbering yeah it's
like a spool but it's thick a little bit
thicker good that all gets woven
together we used to grow cotton when I
was young we're hard and quiet really
mm-hmm
for what purpose just that's just how I
guess I don't know little did I do
something with I don't know random it
was a row of cotton trees so cotton is
like a it's like a almost like a pod
that turns inside out like a popcorn
almost yeah if I remember correctly and
so that cotton would be balls of cotton
you know like you get you know when you
buy cotton balls right yeah I'm sure you
always buy cotton balls but when you buy
cotton balls they're in balls they're
kind of like that but more like there's
not they're not in a ball and a big
clump
okay there's seeds all in there you
gotta pick out the seeds and the seeds
are all stuck to the content I thought
that's how they came but they're they're
twined in or yes spun yeah into string
all right so we got coffee
we got keys we got jeans also I got
jeans by the way oh so you're in the
game now I am totally in the game and
I'm surprised how good okay good
dan I'm sure the buttons brass origin
buttons I was impressed with that when I
saw the pictures when I see him sure I'm
impressed but I'm import maybe I'm more
surprised on top of the impress of how
they fit next level I thought they were
gonna be like the kind older just
generic fitting worker jeans which is
fine I get it but that's not really what
I was like deep down hoping for I was
hoping for the kind that you know I can
put on I can wear to you know if I go
somewhere special with my life or
something like that yes yes they're very
good they fit good hand it to be yeah
that stylish fashion dude leaves a
little bit what it's skinny nice all
right
t-shirts jeans jeez rash guards joggers
supplements yes supplements get your
joint warfare get your krill oil get
your discipline get your discipline go
get these things they will they will
they will make your life better
that's crazy as that sounds you know
they will might make your life better
as will Moke yes and some people say
what is Moke and the answer is very
clear milk is milk is moment that's
right mocha smoke you can't just call it
something you can't call you can't call
a knife by some other name right right
it's a nice knife yeah yeah so you can't
call milk you can't say milk is
something else no mocha smoke then again
I mean hey man Devils that picky you can
call the knife up shank okay a bleed
yeah you're right cold steel you know
there's a lot of words for a knife you
know so there's other words for Molk
than is what you're saying no I'm not
saying that you know just say well milk
is more yeah it is a dessert in the
shape of a protein powder that's healthy
okay so you can either call it that or
you can call it milk it tastes like
dessert
and yet it's good for you and gives you
protein strawberry is delicious mint
chocolate chip I had a I had so much
strawberry I had to go back
two men and I was like good lord ya mean
it's crazy min is delicious I did this
what do you want mint chocolate chip ice
cream milkshake or do you want a mint
Mork oh I'll take the mint mark all day
long oh yeah
short and long-term pale short and
long-term payoff peanut butter Reese's
Cup I don't know if you're allowed to
say Reese's Cup but that's basically
well right yeah yeah peanut butter
Reese's Cup but it's peanut butter and
chocolate mocha tasty what am I missing
vanilla I'm not a vanilla guy I don't
like the vanilla yogurt I don't like
vanilla
the vanilla milk is its if you like
vanilla you're good right
if you don't really like vanilla you
know don't get it there's a whole hoard
of vanilla like crazy yeah for sure
and the thing that's cool about vanilla
I guess is that you can do other things
with it yeah
Jason Gardner put it in your morning
coffee yeah hit it with the he likes to
say hit it with the blender stick right
and you know people some people like to
say things he's like I hit it he gets
all fired up too I hate it with that
blender stick he calls it a blender
stick so there Jason Gardner so in and
Jason Gardner's in great shape getting
after it so maybe it maybe it's a
positive thing and don't forget that
there's a warrior kid mulk cuz do you
want to feed your child poison no do you
I do not okay cool then you get a milk
mmm do you want your kid to to be
miserable when they eat because what
you're feeding them tastes disgusting
let me think
No okay cool - so you give them milk and
you know being healthy and you're taking
care of your kid and you're actually
being a good parent oh yeah yeah
otherwise you're neglecting your child's
welfare don't do it yeah milk strawberry
mocha chocolate milk get some it's true
my dog is in this phase hopefully short
where like she's comparing her body with
like other people's body oh yeah that'll
be a short phase it only lasts like five
hundred years so man it kind of makes
you think like oh shoot she's paying
attention now she got your guns good oh
yeah whatever
anyway uh so Margie over in the corner
doing curls yeah
push-ups and actually she does burp you
know what I tell her it's it's kind of a
trick
I don't tell me if you think this is a
lie so she'll be like hey I don't really
feel like doing the workout today mm-hmm
so I say okay you don't have to do the
workout if and only if you do burpees in
push-ups kind of like burpees and
push-ups are not your workout even
though that is the workout here oh yeah
it's like 70 burpees in like 40 push-ups
or something like that that's the whole
workout and make a six-year-old do a you
know full-on met Conor nothing like that
but I say you don't have to do the
workout you only have to do the push-ups
you like okay you know kind of like she
escaped the workout even though that is
worried is that lying its blanking right
yeah that's like yeah hell yeah unless
you're good that's authorized good yes
anyway my point is that yeah once you
know when when you know I little girl
being conscious of how her body looks
and all this stuff and she makes here's
what is this six men and I kind of feel
this overwhelming responsibility like
hey if she starts like putting on weight
that she doesn't like or something like
that it's kind of my fault you know at
this point it is for sure so the Malka
you can feel real good about it mm-hmm
especially that she likes it you know
and that's job everyone
I don't know how he did that but keep
doing it that's all I know anyway also
chocolate white tea yes can you get
addicted to jakka white tea the answer
is yes yeah yes it's psychological JP to
know GP knows my brother currently I'm
not talking about about him I'm saying
the boys got a little bit of an
addiction problem with the drunk old
whitey all right well there you go and I
I mean I'm sure I haven't thought about
that much but I'm sure there is some
drawbacks to being addicted to chocolate
II I don't know but from here I mean the
intuitive thought is that men that's all
upside addicted to good stuff yeah you
know it's like I am addicted to jakka
whitey and I have an 8,000 pound
deadlift how's it going yeah probably
way more now 1200 or something anyway
yes available cans as well
eggs as well on the store it's on the
stores on Amazon it's everywhere
mm-hmm get it but it's up there yeah
sure get your addiction on something
good also we have our own store speaking
of the stores called jaco store this is
where you can get discipline equals
freedom shirts like I said jockle YT is
on the store it's on the store tins
refills all that stuff hoodies
lightweight and heavyweight hats rash
guards rash guards Oh big time oh yeah
gonna represent the path while you're on
the sport in a rash guard today when I
was doing a ring workout rings we're
using the rings and if you don't wear a
rash guard when you're doing rings if
you do high reps you'll start to chafe
your arms a bunch yeah which is no big
deal but then you get like you know your
if you're doing jujitsu then you're
starting to get little infection
exposures going on so just wear the rash
guard yeah also you know if you work at
the bank or in somewhere where people
sorta have to have at least a little bit
of trust in you if you're rolling around
with chief hands and arms and stuff
they're like wow what's up with this guy
you know they don't know how to just
realize that more well yeah you but
you're like you're like one two levels
like beyond you know like in Fight Club
well you know well this movie Fight Club
word like know I've said yeah you know
when he's at the restaurant he sees it
the two black guys a broken nose and he
trusts some more he says I'm the nod but
a no importance like our clue is this
guy with two black eyes broken nose
changed arms all this stuff with this
guy so weird oh he's doing weirdo stuff
he's doing deviant stuff that's for sure
so you don't want that you don't want
that on the surface is what I'm saying
even though you like it so basically
what you're saying is get a get a rash
guard from the Jocko stores that you're
not weird to other people that's what I
just heard correct just to break it down
simplify what you said also subscribe to
the podcast as I was my kids my children
they were they were going off about some
social media thing and they like smash
the like button yeah so I'm gonna tell
you right now if you're a little younger
profile what I'm trying to say is smash
the subscribe button read don't don't
say that don't try to say that don't
gotta set I don't think you should go
into that whoa wait it falls right in it
goes right into the share layer like
subscribe yeah if you want it's it's
more you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
embrace that I'm gonna embrace that
right now
share like and subscribe share like in
subscriber like you so we shouldn't be
acceptable that I'm like smash the like
button no cuz it's like why tweet why
I'm not gonna do it just cuz you said
it's it should be more of like a
reminder right like if I was all
motivational like you know what you see
that like but you gotta smash that thing
alright don't worry about it we're just
kidding whatever if you want to
subscribe to and subscribe if
subscription is available will say that
just lets leave the button you don't
worry about smashing if you're gonna
smash something smash your next workout
don't worry about the like button don't
worry about the subscribe button smash a
metcon yeah how's that that was good I
was actually really good anyway also yes
warrior kid podcast too let's not forget
about let's never forget it never again
it's hibernating a little bit sure some
people have been to commenting now yeah
there's somebody posted a picture of
like someone that was like Undead yeah
like the warrior kid podcast is by no
means dead it lives on yeah and since I
have just wrapped up a major project I
will have some time hopefully before
certain people are not available to
record to record yeah well so there'll
be some more coming yeah good good
podcast and actually that kind of is
important to know because you know if
they're like hey yeah it's done and they
won't even it won't be on their mind
no-one's even on the lookout for it
then it could go and notice one doesn't
come back nonetheless it's gonna come
back it doesn't have to come back it's
there right now you listen to an episode
it's not that's there okay cool some
people are just discovering that warrior
kid podcast I dig it anyway we're gonna
we're your kids
Aidan's making soap mmm that's right
a goat milk various other ingredients in
America
by the way Irish Oaks ranch Commons
where you can get a trooper soap and
Jacko's so wait does this tell that
you're pursue or was that just a special
edition how's it yeah man and that's
legit no one's on a row but yeah and
what's the slogan I I'd say the slogan
you say but we're better me go ahead
this slogan is simply stay clean there
you go then we have a YouTube channel
and what we would like is for you to
smash this hey we got a youtube channel
if you wanna watching youtube videos if
you're not getting inundated with enough
YouTube videos wasting your time
watching videos of street fights
watching videos of car crashes watching
videos of acrobatic people climbing
around in the city
oh the parkour yeah you know what's
funny it's like you're just totally
putting yourself on report Oh about all
the videos are sure these are the things
like oh you like to watch 3-5 videos
the thing is YouTube knows what you like
to watch oh yeah so it just puts up you
know three on one Jiu Jitsu involved I'm
like oh somebody suddenly made that
video for me so what I'm saying is
subscribe to the YouTube channel if you
want to see the videos that we put out
otherwise go watch some more drunk girl
fails I don't really watch that one but
I will why not like fast tactical
reloads
so anyways there you go boom there it is
yeah YouTube also psychological warfare
if you don't know what that is it's an
album with tracks of jaakko telling you
how to get past moments of weakness if
they may arise if they may arise I went
to it I didn't go to the donut shop I
passed it there's a bank and there's a
doughnut shop right by where I'll isn't
it weird that donut shops exist though
they don't anymore that was gonna be my
point zero people in there
the lady in there so we're wearing you
know what we're winning we're gonna win
I even heard uh what do you call Krispy
Kremes is like either out of business or
going out of business like I don't know
record or something but men the lady in
the donut shop was
um on her laptop in one of the customer
like tables on the seat you know it was
she wasn't behind the counter I know
just coming in here yeah no one's coming
in here at all dang anyway what should
they replace all donut shops with steak
houses yeah well yeah I guess the less
you have this videos yeah just like a
vacant you know what they should do a
vacant building they clear out all the
donut material and machine so I don't
know how you make donuts but clear out
all that stuff and you just put one like
matte space one matte space that's it
enough to end a paper and a pencil you
just sign a name when I came in use this
met me and my partner boom come in leave
but nonetheless psychological warfare
would have seen the tracks about Jocko
can you through your most so what I've
waited the report says that that
psychological warfare the album has done
massive damage to the donut industry
apparently is what's going on that's
what I'm here yeah big time evidently
it's if you don't want the audio version
of that but you want a visual version
you can check out flip side to canvas
comm run by my brother Dakota Meyer and
he makes things for you to hang on your
wall high quality things for you to hang
on your wall to remind you of what it is
that you're doing here so check it out
if you have any suggestions you can hit
up Dakota on social media and tell them
what you want to see so there you go
flipside campus.com
also on it is a good one fun accom slash
Jacko's where you can get your
kettlebells your battle ropes various
fitness equipment is good you'd also get
socks didn't seem like it I know and
I've said it before he gets socks socks
socks or thing I guess well I you know
I'm one of those guys well kind of like
cool socks I don't buy them all the time
but I don't know what kind of guy likes
cool socks I don't know but there's a
whole industry out there used to be and
for me it still is socks means one thing
what pair of white socks
that's a sock Smith well yeah well
you're you
Darth Vader socks like you do or
whatever no I have Darth Vader
kettlebells okay but no no wait the
Darth Vader kettlebells from on it of
course because they got Darth Vader they
got Iron Man they got some good ones on
there also they have like this things
called the elk bars same thing is a
warrior bar but it's been an elk
mmm high in protein really good like a
almost like big beef jerky stick it's
good gift that a lot of good stuff on
there ah Netcom slash job though like
something good something also we got
some books that the books that were
written by John Stryker Myer the books
by written by tilt you can get those on
Amazon across the fence the secret war
in Vietnam on the ground the secret war
in Vietnam and Zog Chronicles Volume one
check those books out there they're
really amazing to read especially and
with their kind of books that when you
read them you have to actually slow down
and think about what the hell is
actually going on man because when you
think about what's actually going on
you'll realize that the what these guys
were doing was just absolutely
completely insane so check out those
books also check out way the warrior Kid
3 where there's a will that book is live
and ready for you to read or if ready
for your kids to read also go away the
warrior Kid 1 and way the warrior Kid 2
marks mission these are good books to
get kids on the path all those little
things that you want kids to know but
they don't really listen to you because
you're their parent this is the ultimate
flank and if you listen to JP Danelle he
says that these warrior kid books are a
flank on the parent - yeah yeah as is
Mikey in the Dragons which is a book for
kids to learn how to overcome fear so
check those out then we've got the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
which will tell you how to get after it
you don't need to ask you can just get
the manual well that'd be nice
yeah oh it's true it is nice yes you get
that Field Manual and you're good to go
if you want them audio version out it's
on iTunes Amazon music Google Play and
other mp3
platforms and then of course you've got
extreme ownership and that I caught a me
of leadership the two books that I wrote
with my brother Lafe babban talking
about everything that we learned in
combat and how you can take those
lessons and you can utilize them with
your business with your team with your
life so check those out
also we got extra on front that's my
leadership consultancy and what we do is
solve problems through leadership every
problem that exists in your organization
is a leadership problem so if you need
help fixing that leadership problem and
thereby fixing the problems that you
have inside your organization go to
echelon front comm if you need further
instruction if you want something beyond
this podcast if you want to come to the
muster the muster is a leadership
training seminar I guess I'd call it
it's a leadership convention and what we
do is go deep dive get granular on
leadership the next one is September
19th and 20th in Denver and then after
that it's December 4th and 5th in Sydney
Australia every single we've done seven
they've all sold out these are gonna
sell out too so if you want to come go
to extreme ownership calm and sign up
and if you can't come to that you can go
to EF online.com and that's our
leadership training interactive online
platform where you can get the skills
you can reinforce the skills the skills
that I talk about on this podcast the
skills that we wrote about in the books
those skills need further training all
the time you never master these things
so go to EF online.com and check that
out and then there's of course EF
overwatch where we've been taking proven
leaders tested leaders from Special
Operations that from combat aviation and
putting them into companies in the
civilian sector that need leadership so
if you're looking to hire don't always
hire you
because someone has experienced higher
for character higher for leadership
capability and then you teach them the
industry specifics because that's easier
than trying to teach someone character
or trying to teach someone leadership EF
overwatch comm if you need leadership
and if you want to converse with us
further then we are on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on that Shh
Vasia posh echo is that echo Charles I
am at Jocko will again John striker
Mayer is at John striker Myer and once
again thanks to John striker Mayer 22
years old putting his life on the line
over and over and over again for our
freedom and to those of you in uniform
right now putting your lives on the line
for our freedom thank you for being
there for us and the same thing goes for
our police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all force first responders out there you
put your lives on the line to keep us
safe and we thank you for it and to
everyone else out there you might be
scared and you might be tired and you
might be surrounded by the enemy who is
preparing to attack but you know what
you're still alive so get the high
ground
set up your perimeter lock and load your
weapons and go get after it and until
next time this is echo and Jocko out